Gentlemen,
Tait Fletcher and Andy's time otherwise known as Andy stumps 77 [inaudible] 76
75 74 although it's taken or was it all taking date?
I'm the only person on Twitter who put the year of my birth after their name.
Spring Hall is pretty fancy,
but some guys just go with 69 that's standard.
I would bet if you search for it's AOL account,
it was a spike man 69 and it was a,
it was a guy I was living with at the time.
He's like,
well I've got this extra account and I'm like spike that.
I'm like what is this all about?
And I guess he like Shit,
chat rooms and stuff.
So that was it for a while until I was like,
I had to send a legitimate email and I'm like this can't be what I'm doing then
I to do business.
I smartly went to rather choke you out,
which looked even when I got into film stuff,
it looks super weird cause you have to send that to makeup,
wardrobe and everybody.
And then it was the end.
It was early in grappling so people didn't know really about fighting.
So you're a sex freak that just likes to choke me.
And I was like,
okay.
And then I got it.
It's funny that you did.
It would be a sex freak and not a violent person.
That just shows you what the circles you're traveling it and that's how small it
was.
Not Sexual at all.
I'm looking over at Tate,
he was like 300 pounds,
rip,
steal.
I'm like,
very few people associate choking with sex this and if you send it into a
wardrobe lady,
it's way better to have her think of you.
Okay.
In this way than that way though.
Right?
I prefer that.
So I just gave,
you know that kind of energy to it,
but then you put that vibe out anyway.
Thanks.
I a sex freak.
Crazy.
What's wrong with being a six free food free?
How come being a food freaks.
Okay with being a sex freak freak is a problem.
It's true.
I mean,
because the puritans,
they can justify food more and then people get mad if you're,
if you're sexually free.
Nobody's happy about that.
People get all weird about that man.
You know,
I've had Dr Chris Ryan on a bunch of times.
He's that guy that wrote that book,
that Guy,
man,
he's fantastic.
He's amazing.
He's,
his book's fantastic.
He's just a cool dude too.
But we always wind up talking about like this weird thing that people have with
people that enjoy pleasure,
like certain pleasure you're allowed to enjoy,
like you're allowed to go get a massage and go,
ah,
the best massage as fucking lady.
She knew how to dig in there and,
but you know,
you say that about getting your Dick Sucked,
right?
You're some sort of a piece of shit,
something wrong with you and yeah,
he's watching this.
You did he,
I had him on out too long ago.
You're talking about all the time.
Yeah,
I've had them on twice in the last couple of months and he's that he's another
guy that confirms everything that I'd heard about Spain like that.
That's the going,
if you were going to move,
so if you could only live in one place,
that that place is fantastic.
Yeah,
he loves it there,
man.
And He's been everywhere.
I mean,
when I met him,
he was living in Vancouver and he was in,
he's in Portland now and then he moved to La for a bit,
but he's been everywhere and he just says,
Barcelona's a spot.
That's dope.
But he knows how to live man.
That dude knows how to chill and he's free.
He's free of the constraints of,
of,
of social norms affecting him and hit him caring too much about what anybody
thinks.
He's probably outlived his parents and whomever that he might've been like.
He,
I'm a little embarrassed if they know I had a threesome or whatever.
You know what I mean?
People live under bondage of other people's opinions.
You just go on blast because he's exactly,
his jar flux is just empty.
Yeah.
I could just sit down some gay stuff.
He doesn't care.
He's like,
whenever I talked to you guys Dick,
or whatever saying he did,
I'm just saying,
you know,
fuck bro.
I didn't know he did some gay stuff.
It doesn't,
it doesn't have to smell really should clean these.
It's one thing that I do not like about these sponges.
I keep thinking I'm,
I'm using the same sponge all the time.
I'm spitting in this thing,
but there's a certain amount of that comes out of your mouth,
no matter what you do.
It's like how much Joey Diaz is probably putting it online or two into that had
to dry out,
but we don't do anything.
I think there's like a way to deal with this and we're not doing it.
We're not doing a damn.
At least I'll breeze it or something.
Jamie was telling me that he,
he replaces them all the time.
He's got a box or
come off these fucking things on these shores.
This is like,
Hey,
I made that.
I made it up.
They probably have a replacement,
right?
There's also cleaner.
I think we can get for it.
Stop it.
You can't,
he can't clean.
This allows you to take these outside to clean stuff that you sponges.
Do you know what you used to clean the sponge?
The garbage.
I mean it is a sponge,
right?
That's what these things are.
These are sponges.
The end game for cleaning.
I think it would a guy like Chris Ryan and the part of it is that he's like,
he celebrated for his openmindedness.
Yep.
So it's like,
it's not just something that he has but he doesn't have to hide anymore.
It's something that a,
he embraces cause other people go.
Thank you.
Finally finding the voice of reason.
Everybody agrees with it to that extent to a certain extent.
It's kind of like being a fighter.
I think in a way is where people are looking at and they're like,
I would've liked to have taken that chance.
I would've,
whenever you're doing anything that people are reticent to jump into and they
go,
man,
I would've liked to join the seals.
I would've liked to have done whatever the thing is in the window closed or
whatever happened.
They didn't have the courage to pull the trigger on it.
But then they see a guy like that and they're like,
he's expressing and manifesting in a way that I would like to be able to do,
but I just can't do it.
I'm caught up in all this other stuff.
Yeah,
people get stuck.
They get stuck in who they are and you know,
they have these ideas of what they would like to be and they just never,
they just never get after it.
They just never,
never hit the gas.
They just never get out of their lane.
They never,
that's a big problem with these huge about freedom man.
People,
people don't,
there's a great argument to be made that people don't want to be free.
You know,
we talk a lot about freedom,
but motherfuckers liked to have handcuffs on.
They'd like to have a wife that's basically like a game warden.
You know,
it tells them what they can bag and when they can come home and you know what
the up it's nighttime,
put the guns away.
I mean most people,
most people to be free would rather
be polyamorous or something like that for sure.
Like,
yeah,
that's how we live comfortably.
But they don't want their wife to do it,
but they don't want anybody to be hurt.
Yeah.
They don't want anybody getting feelings.
Hurt is a lot.
That's the downside.
People's feelings.
That's it.
That's what we walk around really.
You know,
if you're conscious and there's the guys that don't give a fuck.
But yeah.
And then there's also people that hold you captive with their feelings because
they're so fucking ultra sensitive.
Bye Bye.
Ah,
that's such train.
It's hilarious.
The guy like you before this podcast,
you're talking about Tate fighting like you could,
like,
I would never do that.
Never do.
But how could you say that when you were a seal?
I mean,
you,
you were involved in gun fights are in seal team six.
I tell you this jumping knows what he's talking about.
He's talking with his buddy John Wall born.
And then,
um,
with this guy that's a,
I don't know if he's a swat team leader,
but he's on the second one is watching,
right?
And,
and he's like,
he and Scott goes,
yeah.
You know,
uh,
and he's the Swat team guy.
He's like,
you know,
shooting my MP five or something like that.
And he looks over like disgusted,
like Vietnam called they want their guy,
what?
Come on,
what is that four?
And he's,
and he's like,
well no,
like target shooting.
And he says,
Oh okay fine.
He says,
cause I was walking in,
I hit a guy five times in the chest with that and he didn't even really fall
down and he went into the other room and everything.
He's like that.
And that's unacceptable as a weapon.
So the only way I'm,
and I'm looking at this and I'm like,
the only way he sees weapons is worthwhile is their stopping power of a human.
And then he's like,
you really got to hit a guy just under the eyes and just above the teeth.
And when you said above the teeth,
I was like,
that's some next level shit to had referenced.
Sure.
Never forget it.
I'm a little bit and be five.
I didn't say I shot anybody then be five because like I said,
I trained on him in the 90s and then realize that you know,
the turn of the century came so we can put the muskets and the MP fives away.
Wow.
And pickup some other fire number.
No,
I didn't never know.
Catapult still have stopping power.
That's true.
They do
super good.
Bring him back.
I mean,
Gee,
imagine if somebody shot a catapult me,
I'd be like,
I'm out.
You know you're going to,
you're going to live another day like a flame thrower.
If you have a flame thrower blocking you when I like,
I'm not going to go into that.
When you were in the 90s and all the hairspray and everything,
all my money went into beauty products,
which most of us still does.
Honestly.
One of the darkest things that ever heard about warfare was in the Dan Carlin
hardcore history series about the Mongols.
We talked about Mongols lighting,
lighting bodies on fire and launching them with catapults onto the rooftops and
these buildings,
because they had thatched roofs and human bodies,
they get their fatty,
you know,
and the light on fire.
Good.
And they stay lit and they use a bit,
but
it says a guy,
this is great.
Yeah,
so I heard it on a podcast and then I had a guy sitting next to me that also had
experience,
allegedly,
allegedly you need celery.
But I mean I think about it,
think about the,
the impact that that would have being on the receiving end.
You're like,
you fucking win.
Like you know,
if you want to,
all of a sudden your dad comes through the roof.
I mean,
I'm not going to say there's an argument to be made for doing that,
but what if you could do that once and not have to fight to more battles because
the people you want to fight against see that and they're like,
nope,
check you win.
That's the ethical argument for being ruthless,
right?
The ethical argument is if you could be ruthless in a in a short amount of time
and just absolutely stop all the bullshit that you will actually save lives.
Mitigate.
Just cut it.
Yeah.
They look at the atomic bomb,
right?
I mean that was the theory behind that.
We're just going to turn so many people in the glass that your country is going
to want to back away before it happens again.
Didn't they kill as many people with those atomic bombs as they did in like
years of rec?
Traditional warfare?
Sure.
And then I read something too that Japan had already been orchestrating a piece
and a settle
that and they're like,
we're already out in line with this.
We've got to try them out.
Like the little kids giddy for their Christmas present.
They wanted to see what would happen.
Knowing what I know about the u s military,
I'd say there's likely some trans troops.
She was talking to a friend of mine and he was saying also,
he says they want an elongated war.
They don't want.
He's like,
he was a like a force recon guy and he said,
we'd go in and he says,
for example,
there's a house of bad guys,
we know the bad guys are there,
but we get stand down,
just relax.
And then I said,
why?
And he said,
this is a modern day.
Yup.
He said,
because they want it to go longer.
And so then they'd send the regular marines around until they'd get blown up on
the road and then they'd blow up another one and they'd stretch it out for as
long as they could get public opinion of,
of deaths and this and that before they would send guys in and they,
and he said that dates back though to Vietnam.
He said there's a hill that's a famous hill,
I forget the name of it that they retook 15 times.
So yeah,
there's actually,
I think a couple of those,
they made a movie out of one and pissed,
I can't think of the name,
but it's like six oh seven or something like that.
Hamburger Hill might've actually been in the movie,
but yeah,
I dunno man.
That
once you get war gone,
man,
that's big money.
And I mean now that we have a boogie man of terrorists,
you can say that about anything really.
Yeah.
When you have the word terrorists,
that's
to open ended thing.
Cause it's not like there's a country with a leader and you'd take over the
leader and that's it.
You're done.
And then I have to take the inspiration of the government.
It takes the expiration date off because then it's like,
well I don't know.
Yeah,
how long are we going to be there?
What if they move?
Cause then you know what I mean?
It becomes a chess game,
but you're not on a board anymore where the board just exponentially increased.
So how frustrating is that as a soldier?
I mean,
that's gotta be this,
it seems to me that like as a soldier you would want an obvious opponent where
once it's defeated,
you're done,
you have an objective,
the objective is reached.
Everybody can go home.
Like you remember that World War Two photo of the soldier that's kissing the
girl was at a sailor.
He's kissing the girl title the street.
And everybody's like,
yes,
it's over.
Our generation is then denied that we were denied that in Desert Storm.
It's sort of happened because it happened.
It was like so quick.
It's just boom,
boom,
and he gave everybody this idea like,
well,
the way we do war today
is wasn't that big a deal.
We lose a couple of people,
but basically we just go in there and we fuck everything up real quick and
everybody quit.
No,
not anymore.
Now that after that time it became this very murky thing.
It's not going to war with Iraq.
We're going to war with any country is going to war with Isis and they're all
over the place.
There are these,
these boogie men,
Ben,
before that,
al Qaeda.
And then before that she got,
and then it's the whole thing becomes a like a subterfuge and going,
well now we need to be intrinsically laden into these different governments
because they could be,
they're a little bit for ants and they're a little bit,
and then the military industrial complex just grows and grows and grows.
And we take,
I had the benefit though to answer your question because like,
I can't even describe the amount of respect that I have for like conventional
forces and the shit that is forced upon them given their job description.
I mean,
we could spend hours talking about and just like being in an impossible
situation and he's given more decisions to make,
not necessarily horrible decisions,
but they're,
they're trying to the best of the ability that they can,
but there's no time or money or equipment to continue sharpening the blade.
Right?
So they're,
they're large mechanized units or they got to walk around and they'd go out and
they're told to go own battlespace w you know,
and some of the battle is passive.
And some of it's aggressive and it's just,
it's a job where the local people don't want you to be there.
You probably don't want to be there at Super Connecticut and they have to
fucking live there,
you know?
And they,
to them,
I don't know how you define victory to those forces.
For us,
I think we had a little bit of a benefit and it was less frustrating because it
was targeted.
I mean,
we would have a list,
a target list where,
you know,
uh,
like in Iraq in 2005 that we were on full,
like vampire schedule.
I'd sleep all day long,
get up right before the sun went down,
go ahead and workout,
hit dinner,
and I just go sit down in the office and you know,
the cell phone network would crack on it.
It's just who you want to get for just rack and stack them.
So how does that work?
Like you,
you will,
you say the cell phone network would go on?
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
a lot of this stuff,
a lot of the target Nate we would do would be electronic based.
You know,
it's no big Meta data like knowing where the phones are,
knowing where they want the ability to triangulate their location.
It's the same way that your iPhone works.
You know what I mean?
You can,
if you turn on people who think that if you're carrying around an electronic
device and there's not a way to track it,
like this is so open source too.
I mean it's,
you know,
people believe me that Kim conspiracy theorists could go nuts with this,
but with a buddy of mine,
his wife tracked him with a find my phone.
Totally.
I mean what's what and what's the difference?
Right.
It's going off the same thing.
So the phone is communicating with other satellite stuff.
So some phones will become active,
other phones wouldn't,
you know,
you could look at the lines of warfare that we were trying to go down and the
things that we were trying to affect and we're like,
cool.
That guy's number one on the list and it's role.
And for us when we roll.
Now when you decide who's number one on the list,
is that you guys as a group come together?
Is there a guy telling them this is more like kind of looking at the battlefield
and I made,
and the best analogy I could be with like a tree,
right?
So the root of the tree,
so we'll go even bigger like bin Ladin Right.
Like he's right at the base.
Like we're trying to get there but all we can really see is a little branches
and all the out wedding stuff.
So we've got to work our way back.
So it'd be where they are in relationship to the branches and the leaves.
Like how close can we get,
cause it usually starts with a low level guy who you can roll up and you know it
leads to another guy and it's just,
it's a compounding thing.
I mean really that is how as a,
as a,
as a team six guy,
like are you guys as that coming from on high or you guys decided no,
this is the guy that is closest to our objectives as a country.
Both.
It can be both.
A lot of the times,
uh,
like the target deck,
it's you still,
even overseas you work for like a battle space commander and they have
objectives that they're trying to get achieved in that battle space.
So you have to justify what you're going to do against what they're trying to do
right now.
But if there are certain high level individuals that like if that individual
pops up,
you're going to stop everything you're doing and you're going to go after him.
Like Zaas out here,
he was one of them in Iraq.
But you know when we would roll out like a magician is grades are hearing,
we'd roll out and I had a football sleeve on like Tom Brady did with a guy's
picture with stats,
you know,
the picture was fucking completely inaccurate 99% of the time.
Sometimes we didn't have a picture,
she'll be an empty silhouette,
dark haired guy,
bigger than that silhouette.
So I have the droppings on it like a mustache or maybe this guy has to go,
I withdraw,
draw my own little target picture.
But so if the have the building it would have known associates.
So like I,
I had a much more defined end state so we would go and maybe he would be there
and maybe he wouldn't.
So it was,
you know what I mean?
Like at the end of the night you would be able to gauge success or failure to a
small degree as opposed to just occupying a battle space.
Is there ever a time when you got a guy and it wasn't that guy like,
and I know that never happens.
They look just like the picture that I drew on my arm,
but Lauren,
it's like the time to get the donuts guy or they'd be like,
his name is a boost Smith,
which means son of Smith and like everybody's fucking name and the city is a
Buddhist Smith.
So you roll the dude up and you get back and you're like,
this is not,
you know,
these are not the droids you're looking for.
It happens all the time.
But this guy,
what had poor manners.
That's a big argument for Guantanamo Bay,
right?
That Guantanamo Bay,
there's a lot of people over there that were just guilt by association or they
went to school in the wrong place and they attended the wrong meetings and they
just got shackled up and putting some orange jumpsuits and stuffed into some
holes.
So what do you do with them now?
That's a good question.
Especially once you've had them there for,
for shooting is cause they just released a guy.
Yeah he just,
cause we can go down the rabbit hole and this one,
this is a,
this is a tough portion of the question that I don't think people think about
like what do you,
what do you do with a guy who was guilty by association or not but got caught in
the net,
got sent to a place like Guantanamo or other detention facilities around the
world became radicalized and you know,
if you let him out,
he,
if he was in this room,
he would try to kill all three of us right now.
And you know that.
But he hasn't actually done anything yet because
he was put in there by action,
by accident,
by association.
Do you let the guy out?
It's a true,
we'll do you,
I mean it's a very tricky situation depending on what your objectives are.
Are you,
is your objective justice or here's your objective,
making sure that you keep people safe.
Justice [inaudible] yours,
yours,
but you're saying I'm good but you're not in the military.
I had him go Tate and also America's,
you say let them go though.
If he is innocent for sure.
We turn it on.
Sorry,
I'm saying he was innocent when he got there.
For sure.
We've turned everybody that isn't.
If I'm in one tunnel Bay for 14 years,
I'm for sure going to have some feelings.
You're,
you're,
you're going to be totally on the other side,
but correct not for sure until I do that.
Yeah.
I mean ethically you have to turn them.
Typically you have to at the very least wait for something bad watching them.
I might have a sniper attributed to that guy.
Oh,
stop it.
for what?
The fucking 10 yards.
He walks to a vehicle and then disappears into the network.
I mean,
what,
okay man,
come on.
Whatever the thing is.
But the thing is is I can't based on like,
I think that he's going to do this.
Like if we don't live that way,
so then say he does,
so let's say it not a nine 11 scenario,
but say he becomes the guy who goes to France and starts hacking boots with a
machete and you knowingly let them go because you believe in justice.
Yup.
Who's responsible for that happening?
The guy that hacked him up with the machete.
But you're the [inaudible] isn't it?
But it wasn't also the people that turned him into that is really responsible
parties.
You want to run it up the top of the chain,
then it's Dick Cheney,
then it's guys that put him there.
That's guys that didn't,
it's Obama that didn't let them out.
That's a real problem.
I mean that's been a problem since the beginning of time.
It's a rabbit hole,
man.
You can go down and around and around.
Well what at the end of the line,
it's you guys,
you guys are the tip of the spear.
What is the attitude?
Yeah.
What do you think amongst like seal team six,
like how do they feel about these guys that were inaccurately portrayed or
inaccurately assessed and then wound up being stuffed into these hell holes for
years,
tortured,
beaten.
Who knows what the fuck they're doing to those guys?
Look,
we know what happened,
uh,
with those photos that got leaked for what?
I mean,
what the fuck,
man?
It's just a little naked,
pure and some dogs and whatever,
like chemical waterboarding and all this stuff.
Those guys,
I mean,
we know about all that,
right?
So I don't really speak for myself,
you know,
I can't speak for the military,
anybody else,
but you know,
to me it's a very,
very simple decision.
Um,
I'd fucking kill him.
He would kill him because you would think that they would go out and I would
rather err on the side of killing somebody who hasn't done anything than allows
somebody to go out there and perpetuate violence and somebody else straight
across the board.
So you don't think that someone who hasn't done violence,
who has been locked up against their will,
you don't think that they deserve a shot.
You don't think that they deserve like an opportunity to prove that they're not
radicalized or radicalized like that.
It's know you just killed Mandela,
right.
And his Mandela,
Nelson Mandela,
Gandhi,
like anybody.
You know what I mean?
It's like those guys also are in that kind of a position.
It's a good point.
It is a good point.
And like I said,
I can only speak for myself,
and this is probably why I'm not in the position of making policy and I don't
control,
but you're also a guy who has to make split second decisions to save your life
and the life of all the people you love and care for because they're all around
you and they're all in,
in the firefight.
I've seen what these radical people can do,
like firsthand,
like there's what people think that these people will do and then there's the
lowest form of gnarly shit.
Not even the way that the things that they'd done against the u s but like some
of the things that I've seen of how they treat each other in their countries and
these super radicalized areas that are hard to get into.
Like,
I mean it's just,
I don't even know how to describe it.
It's for instance,
give me chaining Mongolian like inbred kids to fucking beds and leaving them in
rooms.
Like in just the way that they'll treat women or like I'd be like,
I entered a room and I didn't even recognize what the the being was and it was
fucking chained to a floor in a room that I went into because it was just
ingrained NBA inbred and they'd go in and know that,
smack it around and throw it some food and like if you're willing to do that to
a human being,
like you don't get a second chance for me.
How often is this taking place?
I mean,
how many people are treating inbreds like this is this like,
I mean that's just an easy scenario that I can come back to.
You know what I mean?
Because that one was like seared into my head.
I'm just like,
what in the hell?
You know what I mean?
But you know,
look at what's going on.
If you're a homosexual over in,
uh,
any isis cereals,
it's thrown you off a fucking roof to the top floor and they're chucking people.
Or here's a better one.
Sex Slaves,
really 12,
13 year olds,
sex slaves.
Like come on.
Like those are the only people doing that or the radical ones,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't have a problem with and Alabama.
Well,
yeah,
but here's the thing,
radicals and Alabama scare the shit out of me too.
Right?
I don't mind moderates across the board.
Like you can be a Catholic,
you can be a Christian.
I don't care if you're Muslim and you're praying in the corner.
I prefer you not detonate yourself afterwards.
Right.
But I'm okay with it.
So I got to,
I want to say,
come in.
Where I come from is like I say what I say,
but like I've sure I would have a different view walking in your shoes and,
but that,
yeah,
so it's,
it's the radicals that once you get to that level,
first off,
like if you're weak enough to have your mind changed like that and you can't
stand for the morals that you know to be true.
Like it's a problem.
Well there's one thing changed and is one thing developed in that environment is
a big difference between someone who's changed and another,
when people,
people imitate their atmosphere.
And if that's all you know,
and that's the world you know,
and you think that Islam is the truth and you think that the Quran is the
doctrine that you have to follow and the 72 virgins awaiting you in heaven,
then sex slaves are permitted.
Then there's all sorts of things that are [inaudible] that you know,
we would of as being horrific that are totally permitted.
It's,
it's,
it's societal standards and culture is a,
is a big part of this.
The way people decide what's acceptable,
what's not acceptable.
So to these people.
I think for us growing up in America,
it's almost impossible to understand what it would be like to be living in.
Like one of the most radicalized parts of the world can understand the radical
behavior,
which is why I have no problem saying that a guy who went and did nothing but
became radicalized.
Like to me that's,
that's a wrote mathematical equation right there.
Like it's a,
you know,
it's a hard one because you know,
people still say to this day and age like,
you know,
you shouldn't,
you shouldn't kill,
right.
We need to,
the counterinsurgency strategy is based off of winning the hearts of minds of
the people that were going in,
into the countries that we're going into.
And I think the only way that I can describe it that makes sense to people,
but it might at least allow them to think outside of the education aspect.
Is that,
and you Kinda,
you,
you alluded to the point a little bit,
but I mean you have daughters,
right?
Do you love your daughters?
Yeah.
Like how much though?
Like articulate for me how much you love.
It's impossible for anybody to ever express it in a way that someone who doesn't
have daughters would ever understand,
or sons or children.
Totally.
And,
and so love is a good analogy because if you can understand how hard it is to
articulate that,
then you understand that there's another side of that coin and that there's a
community of people somewhere in earth that hates you to the exact same degree
that you love your children and can't articulate and would do everything they
fucking can to end our way of life.
Because we let women go outside and have their skin exposed.
You can say what you want,
you can think what you want.
And what's the solution to solve that?
It's not books.
There's not as a single,
I could,
I could put you in captivity for 14 years,
Joe and I could never convince you not to live your daughters.
Right?
There's this,
it's not our job to change.
But what I'm saying,
hold on,
let me,
so what I'm saying is though,
is that people think that there's this,
they're just like,
oh,
you don't have to go over there and you don't have to fight.
Well,
fuck that.
At some point you have to stand up for what you believe in.
Right.
And when it comes to those people that hate you as much as you love your kids,
again,
there's a small segment of that that you could probably turn with books in
captivity,
right?
Which is what's happening to the guys who get radicalized and get mo,
but for the other segment that would like nothing more than to end your life and
everything you believe in.
What's the solution?
It's not fucking books.
Yeah.
What is the solution to try to turn a guy around once they've reached that
level?
Can't radicalization he can't.
So you either have to find something or believe in something to the point that
you're willing to fight for it because here's the deal.
We're x people.
And then there's why people in regardless of what your exes,
your Christian,
Catholic,
whatever your next person,
there's somebody who's a white person,
x and y people are going to fight.
If you believe in what you believe enough then to protect that at some point
you're going to have to go beyond the educational aspect of that.
But isn't that only the case in a place like a radicalized
part of the world?
It's not really the case in America.
In America we have people here.
Well they are but what are they doing?
They're not doing anything.
You know what I'm saying?
Like and maybe it's out of fear and maybe it's out of being outnumbered.
Maybe it's out of the ideal of the people,
but in America if you believe some wacky shit,
like if you're a Mooney or whatever the fuck you are,
we like,
yeah,
he's poor bastard.
He's out there giving money to l Ron Hubbard who gives a fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
But we'd let it go.
I believe that your craziest anything for believing in whatever it is.
I'm not out there trying to change your mind,
but if you look in your neighbor's window,
say if you and you have a daughter,
if you looked in your neighbor's window,
you start your neighbor,
but putting on a fucking bomb vest and a kneeling towards the east and praying
and you had a rifle,
tell me you wouldn't want to put one in his brain right there.
If you,
if you that this guy get a check calendar for us to be Halloween.
So let's not jump to conclusions.
I mean Fuck Joe,
I'm not saying murder Jesus,
right?
I understand that you need to come back again.
It's this coffee,
it's this fucking caveman coffee.
It's very,
very excitable.
And again,
this is a rabbit hole topic to me is the rabbit hole.
You can go round and round and round because people just don't want to say,
yes,
you should kill that person and
I don't,
I'm not,
I have zero problem.
Get up on this thing with end and people like that.
But where do you draw the line and like peop people like it because,
because you can talk all kinds of shit to me.
You can yell at me,
you can do all kinds of stuff to me until you come and you grab my girlfriend
or,
or shoved my mom or something like that.
You're safe.
Yeah.
As soon as you cross the line you're fuck yeah,
but don't.
Well,
when you hear someone talking crazy shit though,
you escalate and you put it in them in a category like,
oh you give him might be a problem.
Now when you have a whole country filled of you might be a problem.
That's when things get real weird.
Right?
But then the problem is how do they get to be that.
Right.
And that's the one of the big issues with the United States,
foreign policy,
military intervention,
military,
industrial complex.
It keeps fucking with all these different parts of the world and puts good
soldiers and good people in jeopardy.
But I for that you'll get,
you'll never get an argument from me.
You'd be amazed at how many people in the military don't necessarily agree with
the foreign policy United States of America.
That's what I was going to ask them.
I know I've talked to them,
I've had emails from them.
I mean I've had a million of those guys and don't think,
don't get me wrong,
like it's after I spent the large majority of my adult life in the military and
I disagreed with a fucking large volume of stuff and where I could push back and
impact that I did and other times when I couldn't.
It's like what can you do though?
It could say if you're over there and you're always responsible for your
personal actions,
right?
So you know it at the end of the day,
most people don't know in Afghanistan up in the [inaudible] valley,
which is like inaccessible and my sheer of fucking reindeer,
or have a c h 47 and you can go up there,
you know,
like you could ask somebody,
hey,
where's the Sama been loud?
And then I'll be like,
who's this been?
You know what I mean?
There's so detached.
So in those environments or any time that
you're actually interfacing with those people or those cultures,
like they're looking at you as the United States of America.
So I can at least conduct myself in a manner that is commensurate with the moral
values that I have,
regardless of my thoughts about the foreign policy of the company or the
country.
You know,
that I'm over there to represent company.
You could say company.
That's right.
Well,
don't think there's a lot of money,
but there's a lot,
believe me,
there's a lot of money made off the military.
That's all the in war for.
I mean,
people think it's to go turn the hearts and,
and,
and plant democracy and all that,
but it's only for money and to feed the military industrial complex.
There is one down the road with you on that a little bit,
but like not,
that's not the only reason that you would think is culpable for one ton animal
bay,
uh,
terrorist being made.
I mean,
who do you think is culpable for going in and attacking sovereign countries?
Uh,
for oil under the auspices that we're going to find.
So you know,
push,
push back on it a little because there are parts of the world where people
become a threat and you have to figure out at what point in time do you step in
and allow these people to get nuclear weapons and do what we did to Japan.
Do you allow these people to get to book?
It wouldn't take much.
I mean one of the things if you read about history is empires fall all the time.
I always have and we are an empire.
Sure.
You know,
whether we were adjust empire,
not his fucking completely debatable,
but there's,
if we fell do it'd be a vacuum and it would be filled.
It's a matter of who would fill it and if you can have something like Isis in
2015 if you can have,
like we saw what happened in Libya was overthrown.
We saw the tech dynamic chaos that's going on right now in Iraq.
I mean,
they're having a fucking Muslim holy war between the Sunni and the Shia right
now,
2015 godly levels that I guarantee you that,
that the modern day media is like sneaking the 1% of the truth on the ground.
Those those guys are fucking insane.
Yeah,
that's,
so this is going on right now.
And we assumed that because the United States of America is the dominant
superpower in the world because we have so much,
and the way we look at things is different.
If you walk through the streets of New York and Los Angeles,
you're relatively safe,
much more safe than any human being has ever been in any other time.
We assume that this is static.
This is going to stay this way,
but not,
not as if there's a bomb.
So it's like that everywhere else.
But yes,
you're right.
That's a very good point.
And that's what sort of dictates our ideas about how the rest of the world
should and shouldn't behave or how we shouldn't,
shouldn't interface with the rest of the world.
But if some shit went down,
fucking nuclear bomb gets dropped in Chicago.
Oh yeah.
Levels the city,
uh,
the infrastructure gets crushed.
The power grid goes down for a couple of weeks.
Chaos,
starvation,
and then an army attacks,
you know,
whether it's the army attacking with fucking drones or satellites or who knows
what the fuck could happen,
right.
But a significantly diminished armed forces,
significantly diminished country.
The whole world could fucking change overnight,
overnight,
overnight.
A natural disaster.
Yellowstone blows,
whole world changes over night.
And we're living like the Mongols.
I mean that,
that literally could happen inside of a year,
inside of a year,
a whole world to do a total one 80.
Yup.
So the United States armed forces or any armed forces that is in a position of
power that has a,
a moral,
a moral and ethical imperative.
If they're looking at people like isis,
they're looking at,
regardless of how they were created,
regardless of whether or not these guys were formed in Guantanamo Bay against
her will,
you got to figure like,
what,
what's the end game here and how do we,
how do we engineer the future?
But do we have a moral and ethical,
uh,
government or,
or military,
I mean in,
in those ways it's like,
or is it chasing greed?
I mean,
at the,
at that point,
I,
I look at it and I go,
is our best course then to go out and eradicate people or is it to change our
foreign policy?
And,
and to not be kind of,
um,
bullish in the world?
It's a good question,
but you kind of got to deal with what the table is right now in 2015
Norwood's like at your doorstep.
But I think there's truth to what,
what do you feel?
Yeah,
I think there's,
well,
I'm not in it anymore.
Uh,
I think there's truth to both.
I liked like Joe Sam,
like if,
if the pizza guy's ringing your doorbell,
you know,
you might want to go handle that,
but at the same time,
you know it,
you need to go and think about,
I personally believe you need to think about the things that is causing and
shaping the world.
Like,
let's draw isis back.
Where did it come from?
Okay.
Well it didn't,
we build them to fight Syria.
I wouldn't say we built him to fight Syria,
but like let's take it back to nine 11 right?
Like why did we go to Afghanistan in the first place?
Why did we go to Iraq?
Right.
Go to Saudi Arabia First Party.
What's it?
Yeah.
So as far as Afghanistan though,
like you want to talk about something that I think,
you know,
they definitely were,
it was a,
not a breeding ground,
but it was a place where people felt safe to go and train to do harm to the
United States.
So going there to push that out of Afghanistan I think was a solid move.
Right,
right.
But you know,
you fast forward 14 years and I think we largely self created the problem,
right?
Because we occupied,
we push them out
now
they're like fuck you.
And then they learn just like we do.
Like it's an amazing game of chess.
It's just like,
the only difference is,
is like playing chess and a drying machine and it's on.
So the board is constantly shifting and you got to keep track of all your
pieces.
So we went in and invade,
we push out.
Uh,
now they know they're not safe in Afghanistan and they know it's no longer safe
to,
you know,
cohabitate in one area.
So what do they do?
They disaggregate and then they get Iraq and Afghanistan.
Then they dis-aggregate,
you know,
and all the other areas around the world,
they start communicating with the Internet.
So we actually made the problem exponentially harder for ourselves with the best
of intentions or did we have the intention to make it harder?
Obviously you can choose,
you can choose any of the that I think people are opportunists and this is like
the argument nine 11 being an inside
job,
right?
I think it's much,
much more likely there was incompetence and then that people capitalize on an
opportunity to do something they've always wanted to do.
You know that I've Afghanistan and you know that Dick Cheney and Bush had been
talking about going into Iraq and trying to form a strategy.
If you're going to Iraq for a long time,
nine 11 comes around and they're like,
look,
we got it.
Here's our,
here's our reason that the idea that that was all orchestrated is a very
convoluted idea and I don't necessarily think the facts support it.
I think the facts,
if you look at human history,
it's way more likely that you're dealing with massive and competence.
Then you're dealing with a massive conspiracy.
What do you think about Arab spring?
You ever see Wesley Clark General Wesley Clark?
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Well I think that's it.
I think he's 100% being honest and accurate about that when he's talking about
all the different plans and the strategies of inventing all these different
places.
But I think that when something like nine 11 comes around,
it's a green light for these assholes.
And before this happened,
I think they were just,
they just didn't have a real way to do it.
I think you've got both is what I'm trying to say.
I think you've got both in competence and then you've got people like Dick
Cheney that are clear chicken hawks and was fucking,
I mean you can't be any more transparent than the guy that's running a company
that rebuild shit after we blow it up and then decides to go blow shit up.
I think there's actually a lot of uh,
supporting documentation to like there being a lot of the chicken hawk stuff,
people just standing by like they want to do stuff and they're waiting for the
impetus where it's going to be.
The society would be like,
yes.
They'll be like,
be like,
yes.
Okay,
you can go do this.
Because in a lot of that stuff and a lot of that,
you know,
the,
the military machine and,
and once it's,
the cart has left the barn,
is it tough fucker to get back in the barn.
So they had definitely had plans,
like there was preexisting plans for the invasion of Saudi and even for Oif,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it definitely existed.
Lf Operation Iraqi Freedom.
Okay.
OEF is Afghanistan.
They since changed the names to,
I don't know what it is,
but I think it's both like nine 11 is it possible that that was a convincing
conspiracy?
Sure.
Is it plausible?
I don't think so.
I believe exactly.
You do the gross in competence because I go through the airport all the time and
I see the people who are screening meet this day.
And I know for a fact that it was gross in competence because the guy's fucking
drooling looking at the little monitor coming by,
you know what I mean?
Is My bag goes through.
So I think it was a combination of the two,
but I don't know.
I mean,
I think that you're confusing.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna say,
I think you're confusing politicians with the military.
Right?
You might be surprised at how little,
I think most politicians have any effect over the military themselves.
I don't think they have a lot of effect over the government either.
I think that the,
no,
they don't.
Right.
And I,
and I'm certainly pro military to 1000% think that people get tricked and they
get put in an impossible situation possible to it.
You can only be 100% of anything can be 1000% tape take,
10% doesn't exist Tate.
So Tate's king for a day.
Like I was going to ask you about that.
What was your,
what's your first move?
You're king for a day.
You got 24 hours to set a policy in place.
It's going to last for for 12 months.
You've got 24 hours of time.
Sure it is.
I'm gonna need a couple of weeks.
You have to,
once you fly,
you need to grow the mushrooms Obama had,
I need to figure out how to get them to the Middle East.
I need some time and just,
yeah,
I need to figure out a way to starve these people to get them to eat mushrooms.
I'm going to get them covered in chocolate or camel or whatever the fuck they
eat.
But it's a tough question,
right?
Because everybody will sit back and they'll tell you how it's fucked up.
But like,
all right,
right.
What would you do?
What did you do?
Well,
I think you got to destabilized corporations and,
and that kind of
anarchy talk from a guy who drives a Toyota.
What's the fuck are you going to ride a camel to work around?
Did you stabilize and corporations change Tesla,
you looking at anything like that?
Mother,
the fuck is a corporation.
But the idea that it's different if you have a corporation with,
uh,
unabashed drive for profit,
you're in a bad place.
And that's where we are.
Well,
that's what's wrong with our country for sure.
Yeah.
Well,
when you have unlimited growth and that's you,
that's your motto.
Yeah,
that is a real issue.
That's a real issue because of Bart and tonic,
just behind your corporation.
That's different.
But right now we have politicians that are simply a shadow of corporations with
is also,
is also a problem that when a corporation does something fucked up,
the people inside the corporation aren't held responsible.
Like individuals do have a diffusion of responsibility.
Well you guys,
you know,
cause you're not a bad guy.
You're not a bad guy.
I'm not a bad guy.
We're all just pushing her pen this way,
in that way.
Right?
So you can do a certain number of,
okay,
like let's look at caveman coffee.
Caveman coffee is a small company,
right?
Well,
what if caveman coffee grows to be something like Folgers and Maxwell House and
we find out that you,
you guys are chatting people,
right?
But how does that happen?
How does a company like Halliburton come about?
How did,
how does it get from an idea to a few employees read an Ego,
right?
I CAS greed is a big one.
And then the business model is a big one,
right?
And then the ability to justify and rationalize fucked up decisions,
The diffusion of responsibility that comes from a large group acting in a fucked
up way.
Yup.
Yeah,
exactly.
So let me ask you this,
because as a decorated veteran who's seen combat,
what if in hindsight is of course 2020 not,
not criticizing any decision that had been made,
but if you saw not what you've seen and you see nine 11 happened today,
what's the move?
What do you do?
Do you invade Iraq?
You know,
I am guilty of personally believing the spin that was on the Iraq war.
You know what I mean?
It's a,
you'd be believe it currently or you believe that?
I believed it at the time.
You know what I mean?
Everybody did.
Colin Powell was on TV so credible and my dad would be like,
he was at this hurt your dad.
My Dad is a Vietnam vet.
He'd be like,
no,
this is,
this is fucked.
This has got all your dad thought
that he did.
He,
what did he think?
What was his name?
He was just like,
no,
this is bullshit.
We have no business going in there.
There's two aren't connected.
Right.
Cause they tried to tie then know Kate is from Afghanistan to Iraq.
And I would argue with them,
you know,
and,
and I believe it.
I mean the first target we hit in Iraq was the number one chem bio target in
that country.
And it was a fucking agricultural school.
It was growing tomato plants.
Wow.
So was that just bad intelligence?
You know,
we looked at that target for a couple of weeks.
We had schematics,
we had experts on air conditioning coming and telling us,
you know,
like,
look at this,
look at all the air conditioning that they have.
It's like,
it's for the ventilation system.
And now in hindsight,
I'm like,
it's really hot there in the summer.
That's probably why they had all that.
It gets like 140 fucking degrees in the shade,
you know,
and then like,
oh,
but look,
you know,
there's this tube that comes out twice a year.
It was,
which is to the greenhouse,
you know?
Uh,
so I mean,
not only did I believe it,
but we were pursuing it as,
you know,
we were going after chem bio stuff.
Now,
in hindsight,
uh,
I don't think I would have myself personally if I,
you know,
if I was,
I thought I was king for the day,
I wouldn't have invaded either.
If I could use modern day technology.
And this is still what I think I personally would do today is I would pull back
all the US forces in Afghanistan and the ones that are in near Iraq and instead
of occupying,
which has been proven to be ineffective time and time and time again.
I mean it creates enemies.
Oh my God.
Well just ineffective but effective in creating enemies.
You know,
it's like look at the Russians death by a thousand paper cuts,
right?
Way Worse than a blow to the head that ends it initially.
So I would,
I would pull that out and not go down that road and I would go very,
very surgically and I would,
I would develop the intelligence,
uh,
to be certain of the people that were looking for.
You know,
you got to leverage the assets and in,
so sometimes you might be wrong with the surgical strikes,
but I'm okay with that.
But I would go surgically as,
as opposed to occupying and I would leverage all the resources to do it that way
as opposed to putting an infrastructure in place that cost billions of dollars
to support.
Cause you're a goddamn American.
Andy's done last time I'm back.
Yes.
I was not like these cock suckers that put us into this.
God Damn.
And that's the American surface.
But I got,
I'm [inaudible] Sam 15 yeah,
exactly.
I'm looking at this in the rear view mirror and I was just as guilty.
I'm like fucking God dammit of some a bin Ladin is in Baghdad.
I'm like,
that's like that's where everybody thought he was.
Not at all.
But you know what I mean.
They made the connection,
they made the connection that al Qaeda has a loose connection.
But you know,
again it's fuck hindsight's 2020 but again,
you just can't occupy.
You cannot occupy cause it doesn't work.
Now do you believe that?
Like,
so when you say go in and you kind of change policies and your,
you're working assets that are there,
you get more assets.
If you're judicious,
right?
You get more assets.
Do you believe?
Do you believe in a universal justice and harmony and that way of like if
America is behaving in a proper and appropriate way in the world,
yeah.
There's to be radical assholes
that are here and there and whatever,
but there's going to be assets within those countries that are going,
this is working for righteousness for all people.
Is that a thing?
I don't it to be,
I don't think that the scales would balance in that regard because you're
talking about the difference between rational thought and irrational thought and
irrational people.
Just take it too far.
You know what I mean?
You got to pound on one side and then an irrational guys got two pounds,
so you could have a million people,
you know,
rationally thinking or nine people with fucking box cutters,
irrationally thinking and you can look at,
you know,
what happens,
you know?
I mean,
did scale is just don't,
they don't balance themselves the way human nature is.
As you always look at it,
it's all,
you only vote for what you don't like.
You don't really vote for what you liked them.
You know?
It's like,
that's Kinda how we're cut in a way.
Well,
it's easier to point out things that are mistakes and it's easier for me to
articulate bad leadership and be like,
good leaders should be like,
what is it that he's doing?
How difficult is it to,
to try to formulate correct intelligence about a country in the other side of
the planet and what are you doing to get,
that's one of the things that's always gotten me like what are they using the
using satellite imagery,
the of your knowledge and everything.
Each of the architectural schematics of the buildings we try CIA guys on.
They're not very accurate.
I mean,
what can you do to try to figure out what they're doing?
Like,
you know,
I had this conversation with someone about Isis,
like yeah,
we need to just go over there and take care of that.
I'm like,
what are you,
what are you saying?
Like where are they?
Yeah,
exactly.
So go ahead.
To me a,
draw me a map of where this,
this isis that you'd like to have taken care of is and when you realize it's
populated across multiple countries and they communicate over an electronic
medium that we can't control and they don't get together cause they understand
what happens when they do get together and they communicate through fucking
photographs that you could send on Instagram.
They could send a photograph on Instagram or on Youtube that can send a video
and have metadata in that photo that you have to eat.
They have to take it.
Then they send it through a filter and they figured out what you're trying to
say.
Well you could send them a picture in an email,
hey man,
just chill in here and fucking Canoga park eating a sub,
you know and have you with a smile.
The meatball sub and there's metadata in that they can transcribe and then they
figure out what the fucking messages,
I mean that that was a lot of how they were communicating back and forth was
with encrypted data is almost like,
uh,
like gang is con savagery there.
5,000 guys are going in and turning 50 thought a city of 50,000 away and they're
running before they get there.
Oh yeah.
Those,
those guys can find,
they put dudes in cages with a trail of gas and we designed them on fire like
damn dude.
Like that's,
and they filmed it in slow motion.
Yeah.
I mean they like to use high tech equipment.
That's the other thing is that they have access to equipment and in the high
tech technology that,
you know,
technology has reached,
this is such an incredible level that the average person has access to some
pretty fucking significant shit.
And if you're an evil person on the other side of the planet,
you can keep track of a lot of stuff going on.
Mean drones.
Fucking anybody can buy a drone now,
right?
You could have drones up in the air with video cameras and the guys are good at.
Um,
yeah,
I mean you could do,
they operate on cell phones.
You know,
they have drones now that work on virtual reality headsets.
I've,
I've used them.
You put a virtual reality headset on and you have a drone flying around and he's
fucking see everything.
Yeah.
I mean there's so much that we can do now as like regular consumers.
You've got to imagine what the amount of money that a group like isis has.
I mean,
they'd been stealing money for a long time.
Now they have fucking billions of dollars.
And that's why I think occupation doesn't work.
I mean it's,
it may be,
you know,
maybe have a presence at a base nearby so you can have a staging point.
But I think we're,
I think that everything has changed from,
I don't think you're going to see these mature battle areas anymore.
He made me mature areas of war because it's all gonna be surgical.
At least I hope because that,
again,
that's,
that's the direction that I would go with it.
I mean it's lower risk than exposing a large force over a truncated time period.
And isn't there also a big issue right now with our drawn out sort of cold war
battle being brought back to life.
We've got a real issue now with Russia,
right?
I mean this,
this whole Putin thing,
it seems,
it seems like there's a,
there's a real animosity between Russia and the United States that is rekindled
that we didn't feel for decades.
You know,
Putin has kind of brought this back to life and strategically if he should
decide to align himself with people that are the friends of Isis,
like not unnecessarily isis themselves,
but just close enough and close enough proximity that he can sort of fuel that
fire.
Whether it's with information,
with strategy,
with money,
arms,
equipment,
like nuclear bombs.
I mean that's the ultimate,
right?
That's what everyone's more,
more terrified of than anything is that some radicalized crazy fucking group
gets a hold of a bomb and decides to blow Paris up or decides to blow.
Can you imagine whatever downtown New York and somebody clocks one of those
things off.
I think that's the spot,
right?
New York is a spot.
If you want to get a lot of attention,
they've hit it twice.
Right?
That's the spot.
That's the,
the,
that's the,
the epicenter of attention for terror in the world.
If you want to really make a fucking big splash,
you go to New York,
but not,
it's been there twice,
allegedly.
Who knows.
Moves are ghost,
could be still alive.
Tate loves this Bin.
Ladin like two bucks.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
there's,
there was a great article from a fucking during when the,
when bin Laden was involved with the Mujahideen,
I forget what publication it was in,
but somebody posted it recently and it was when bin Laden was our ally.
And,
uh,
there was this like puff piece on bin Ladin and real important it is that bin
Ladin see,
see if we could find that Jamie,
if you find it.
I,
it was,
it was during the time when Russia was invading Afghanistan and we were arming
the mujahideen and we were training them and helping them to fend off the Soviet
Union because we don't want to rush and pipeline.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a classic enemy of our enemy.
Exact scenarios.
What played out exactly,
and they were making it out like this guy who was CIA trained,
this guy,
Osama bin Ladin was,
you know,
was it a real hero and then turned on America and you know,
to them it's the best piece of evidence.
If you look at the way we respected and trained and thought of Osama bin Laden
and then Osama bin Ladin became our number one enemy.
It's the best piece of evidence that the United States is evil and corrupt to
them.
I mean,
it's like,
look,
this is the guy that was your number one guy over there.
He was the guy that you trained to fight off the Russians and now he's saying,
you know,
the Russians were a problem.
The United States is a bigger problem.
This is the real problem.
And then boom,
everybody is the story of the prodigal son gone bad.
Do you think that they,
what do you,
what is your thought on the Osama bin Ladin the killing of Osama Milan and
dumping them in the ocean?
Two thumbs up,
but not necessarily.
I would imagine that.
But I mean,
do you think that definitely happens?
Cause I've talked to guys,
I've talked to special ops guys that don't even believe that happened.
They go,
I think that goes dead.
They like,
we think that guy was dead for a while and they think that that's why isn't his
fucking Cryo chamber somewhere in Pakistan?
Pictures of him.
There's no,
there's no any,
there plenty of pictures of him.
No.
But I know guys who have firsthand sounds like Ufo people.
I've seen the photos.
Yes.
Seven 47 when they fly over a spraying chemical con trails as well too.
It's not just the condensation in the air though.
He knew.
No,
I haven't personally seen him.
Uh,
you know,
I wasn't there.
I had left the command long before that actually happened.
But if talking to people that were there,
I have no reason to doubt the people that I've talked to that were physically
present when it happened.
And so you've talked to people that were there for sure as it happened.
Yeah,
absolutely.
100% by the official narrative.
Yup.
Okay.
I'll banded my conspiracy.
I mean that's like,
no,
but what is in there with a conspiracy is that he was there,
he was dead and that they were waiting for a strategic time to,
what's the value of killing us on Milan.
It was when the election or reelection was happening,
I could buy it.
Okay.
So you think it was purely a political play?
That's,
that's the conspiracy theory comes about because why do you make his body
disappears or nobody can ever see that there's not genetic testing all that.
That wasn't the idea.
Yeah,
we'll do it.
And then there was DNA taken.
Okay.
Uh,
and I can tell you the reasons that I was told is,
you know,
by leaving the body there,
it would have basically turned that into a new,
I don't want to say it,
Maca cause that's the wrong word,
but a new shrine to whatever he stood for.
So they removed the body,
uh,
gave it the Muslim burial that it deserved or did not,
depending on,
you know,
which way you swing on that opinion.
And what's the Muslim burial?
I think it,
uh,
I'm not an expert on,
but I believe it's a requires a certain amount of washing.
You have to be shrouded in a certain way.
And then,
yeah,
I mean,
I would rather have that,
I would rather either cremate the body and get rid of it somewhere or put it
somewhere that people can't go to and,
and worship some douchebag.
Right.
You know what I mean?
If you look at what's happened since then,
it was effective because even though,
I mean he is a,
a revered guy in that culture,
there isn't a spot where you can go to the,
they think of as this holy spot where he died and even though he has been a
martyr,
there's,
there's no images.
They probed around social media.
So they did mitigate that.
Yeah.
By not releasing the images,
I think it's better.
Right.
I know,
I know for a fact that they did DNA testing,
you know,
he has relatives that have come to the u s it wouldn't be impossible to get a
DNA strand that you could match back to the guy.
So,
you know,
as far as the execution goes,
I mean,
I think,
I think it went really well.
What did it have a political gain?
I think you can't argue that it didn't,
you know,
it definitely did.
But in my own mind,
I don't know if that's enough to justify a conspiracy.
I buy the,
you know,
maybe I'm an idiot,
but I buy the,
uh,
you know,
no,
the official narrative makes sense.
I just,
it's,
conspiracies are fun.
I get it.
I get excited about them.
I mean,
that's,
I think that's what it gets a little people wrapped up in bigfoot or chem trails
like for sure,
like,
like going into Iraq.
You're like,
for sure that's bullshit.
Like for sure.
Now I say that.
I wasn't saying that,
but there's,
there's stuff we're billions of dollars goes towards that.
The devastation of millions of people and all that stuff for not,
not,
not for the,
just cause that we think of it.
You know,
what we know about,
how about we know about for sure,
like the negotiation of the,
the,
the hostages in Iran during the Carter Administration.
They made sure those hostages were not released until after Reagan was
president.
Yeah,
that's a fact.
We all know that.
We all know that for political gain,
they left those Americans in trapped that we know that.
Let's be honest,
if anybody thinks of politician is out for anything other than themselves or
their own,
you know things that are good for them,
then you're probably operating from a not a really good standpoint.
Say that,
but if you seen Bernie Sanders photo of him with Jesus,
because I don't know what the fuck you're talking about now.
Now you're talking crazy D's get Jesus is literally his homeboy.
I have the same picture in my office.
Joe,
you don't.
I'm getting one.
Does a guy who's making them,
he's making prints.
We're going to hang out up in the office.
I said,
what did I say?
Bernie Sanders.
Did I say Bernie Sanders?
Dammit.
They're all crazy to me.
They're all interchangeable.
I should have said Hillary Clinton.
You've achieved another level.
Well,
when he's do it as an abstract watercolor painting of Jesus loving your
shoulder,
it's not abstract.
It's as it happened to go.
Okay.
Got It.
It was actually just in life,
not Bernie Sanders.
I think that we need a fucking a Brian Stann Press Fox next.
Really,
because I feel like the next president,
if it Putin is the real deal in that and he is man,
that dude is a g like he's scary.
You need to have a guy as president that's willing to get on a horse and joust
him to death or something like that.
Like you gotta have somebody viable up there.
It can't be these fucking people that are available now for us.
That's not going to work.
Well.
Could you imagine what like if Putin and Obama had a fight to the death,
how embarrassed we would.
That's what I'm saying.
We need Brian stands.
How quickly would Putin trip Obama and have him on his back and just be beaten?
His brain can't believe you actually had to make that analysis can be stuck in
my head.
It's just what it would have been.
The idea clinch up on his back mount of time out elbows to the eye sockets,
just death.
It would be horrible.
I mean we are,
I mean,
we would never grow our dicks back in America.
Is that a problem?
And we do.
Do we need a leader that knows how to find yas everybody?
Teddy Roosevelt.
Who?
Who's the last guy?
Ronald Reagan was probably like,
like a guy that you would think of as being a tough guy,
but he was up,
it goes down.
He pretended to be a tough guy.
You do is backwards.
So who else?
George George W.
Walker.
Yeah.
He killed a bunch of motherfuckers knife in your yeah,
he would,
he would kill you with a pen.
Yeah.
He's forgot special pens made the first g Bush.
Yeah,
the old dude.
Yeah.
He was the head of the CIA.
Yeah,
that's,
it was bad ass.
He was legit.
So who else?
George W.
No,
but you look at,
yeah,
it's so sad.
It is teddy,
Teddy Roosevelt
who go Chavez.
Putin.
And you look at all these other leaders there.
They're like,
you're like,
that dude's probably about some shit dark guys.
And you're like,
that's an impotent old dude.
Bill Clinton,
I bet.
Could make some fucking phone calls.
That's true.
He might not be.
I'll kill you himself,
but I bet Bill Clinton make some phone calls and he could charm the socks off
you.
I don't know about all that.
Come on.
I don't think so.
I know too much.
I don't know too much and look at his eyes.
I would see him Mcdonald's eating fucking jog and motherfucker jog.
I remember,
I remember the old days,
I don't give a fuck with this new Vegan Clinton.
This new guy was buying the China study,
which by the way it's been disproved bills.
Go read into it.
Biased information,
sir.
Kevin used to be mad all the time.
I'm like,
are you trying to study?
Yeah,
like he would post shit like that.
I'm like,
you need to read more books.
Well,
the China study makes some good points about the American diet.
The typical American diet is terrible.
All that other stuff like conspiracies.
It's like there's enough truth mixed in with all this other stuff.
Yeah.
What's this bias information?
You know,
you buy a sampling,
pick the stuff that you want that supports your idea.
Look like good food is good for you.
You know,
eat a lot of vegetables is great for you,
but eat only vegetables.
There's not really a lot of evidence that says that's the way to go unless you
have a specific bio situation.
You know,
like some people do have issues,
million people in the u s that many.
It's like statistics,
statistics.
You can mean,
I know people that like,
like their body processes fish better.
They eat meat.
They far too much.
They don't like it.
Yeah.
You can justify any argument you want with a little study statistics.
That's not
Dr. Tate.
That conspiracy.
Yeah.
Well people love conspiracies,
man.
Hey lesson.
You just admitted that you fucked up about Iraq so you can't tell
others fucked up.
And I was unwittingly caught up in the next [inaudible] your mind.
Fuck you.
I don't unwittingly.
We're just very lucky.
Eddie Bravo is not here right now.
He will tell you.
Oh my God.
That's why I brought that up.
I heard somebody talking about it the other day,
like while pointing at the aircraft,
it's apparently spraying agricultural style.
I'm like,
what does southwest airlines,
yeah,
well it's this Guy Mick West that runs a site called metal bunk.
Oh God.
It's a debunking website.
It explains in very objective detail why most conspiracies bullshit and
explains,
you know,
and that's why it's called Metta bunk.
And uh,
he,
he calls it the training wheels of conspiracies and he's like,
cause it's right there.
It's up in the sky and you know,
you look,
you think about your childhood,
you go,
I don't remember those being there when I was young and just decided that they
weren't there.
I'm not as photos from like old Clint Eastwood Movies where this Ken trails in
the background or country in the background.
I'm a western Joe.
Yes.
No,
they didn't have planes bang out.
I know,
but that's what's fucked up.
These dummies,
they're out there doing films and above them in the skies fucking controls.
That's a curious,
that was a gassy oxen.
Well this real,
this real conspiracies.
I believe in all of them.
Well the,
the best one is asking,
right?
All of course he is.
[inaudible] there's no way you can know everything.
Right.
That's part of the problem.
There's no way.
And we know that people have done some DV Shit in order to make money in order
to cover their tracks or in order to,
I mean,
it's just,
that's why when someone finds out about something like weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq not being real,
and they immediately go to the conspiracy angle where a guy like you who was on
the ground can say,
well look,
we really thought that was the case and it's really hard to gather up that
information.
I mean,
it's embarrassing to say looking back,
but I mean that's,
that's where our head was at.
Those are guys on the ground.
It's easy to convince guys on the ground of stuff.
I'm saying the guys that put you on the ground,
do you know what I mean?
It's like they knew
that they couldn't find it.
What they said,
there's no evidence that there's no weapons of mass destruction there,
like time and time again.
And that's why,
what's her name?
The CIA agent got outed by those mother fuckers by,
uh,
yeah,
that was buying 10 star.
Right.
And so there's that.
Right?
Because her husband gene,
her husband was supposed to come back with evidence,
says I w and George says,
I want you to find weapons of mass destruction here.
And he's like,
there's just not.
Yeah.
And then she's an undercover CIA operative and they outer in Africa while she's
undercover.
When the world was turning off.
Valerie plot ballet plume.
Yeah.
Wow,
man.
You get it.
Steel trap memory over there,
Joe.
I remember some,
she lives in Santa Fe.
Does she?
Why you out or your address?
Tate.
She's,
what does she do?
Where does she take her?
[inaudible] she's not into zoom.
Osha does crossfit.
Okay.
Oh Jesus.
Which I've heard
is Joe's favorite,
but that's one of my favorite things to do.
He just doesn't know enough.
Well,
I do a lot of the exercises that they do on the cross and that Joe.
Okay.
You're a crossfit guy,
right?
Sometimes I'm,
I'm more endorsed for that company for eight years.
For crossfit.
Yeah.
What's up with the did number one dude being fat?
He's in good shape.
I just saw him this summer.
There's no way.
It looks great.
Not like this mother fucker come on.
Who is like that?
Hey,
you know,
it's uh,
I like it when you do the one bicep and then the this and then the
fucking nice.
You know what I mean?
The program came from between his ears,
you know what I mean?
So,
okay.
So it's knowledge is as opposed to,
yeah.
A lot of experience doing it.
Is that g though,
man,
he's,
he's changed the lives and he's changed the face of fitness for,
uh,
for everybody.
Like he's,
he's definitely,
if you want to talk about somebody that is exact,
a change upon the American population and diets,
that's the guy man done done some huge,
huge way,
but his company has done it right.
And then when people see him,
they go,
hey,
yeah,
come,
you don't look like you do it.
I mean,
it's a tough one.
I don't know what he would say if you asked him straight to his face.
I don't know what he would say if you asked him to partake in crossfit work.
He's Kinda like a bad body.
Right?
Something wrong with him.
Right.
He's got a bum leg.
Yeah.
And he was like,
he was right.
That was what he,
he bicycle,
he has a passion for bicycling.
Right?
Oh,
I don't think he ever did it competitively,
but it was just the flight fly forum or so I did,
I started off the fly planes.
I got about 3000 hours flying me some jets.
Wow.
I dabble in a lot of the shit that company for a long time.
For four years.
I taught at the,
uh,
the seminars just teach,
like basically spreading Greg's conceptual foundation all over the world when
all over.
And then I manage the licensing and sponsorship deals when I came back off of
military deployment in 2010.
So I've managed the Reebok deal that crossfit has,
uh,
and then started flying again and then flew him for like three years as well
too.
So I was,
I was in the military doing all that double dipping while I was in.
What is your feeling on crossfit?
You can't argue with the effectiveness of the methodology.
Like it totally works.
I S I mean,
the days of pumping iron and Arnold Schwarzenegger were awesome.
You know what I mean?
And I'd rather have people do that than sit on the couch and eat Doritos.
But I think the argument for functional fitness and the ability to actually be
able to do something with all the hard work you're doing,
you can't argue against it really.
Right.
It's,
it's form over physique.
Uh,
and I,
I it,
I need to be able to do it to do the activities that I still do.
Like I'm outside all day long,
you know,
eaten shit all the time.
Uh,
so yeah,
I mean,
again,
a long,
long answer to a short,
short question.
Uh,
I do it.
Yeah.
The argument against it by guys who are very knowledgeable about strength
conditioning is that you shouldn't do power lifting exercises for large amount
of reps and that it's damaging for the body.
That's like with Steven Mandell's says,
he says Olympic lifting,
power lifting.
There's a distinction.
Okay,
well,
dead lifts and cleans like that kind of shit or lifting,
right?
It's cleans and snatches are thing is more like dead lifting.
Olympic lifting is like the tiny and make opening and closing like the snatch,
the corral,
all that stuff.
Can you get,
can you go overboard?
Sure.
But you need to kill yourself drinking too much water too.
I mean you've got to put that in perspective.
Well Maxwell's problem with it has always been that it's a competition for
exercise where he feels like exercise should be used to get you in better shape
for competition and then having a competition out of lifting weights,
you know,
and for a bunch of repetitions is silly.
It is silly.
But I also,
I would also say that's a bastardization of what the company actually stands
for.
The competition aspect was in a group classroom setting.
And if you take that and expand it beyond that,
it stops making sense at an exponential rate.
It was just about putting,
you know,
a number on a board and holding you accountable for your performance.
If you're racing,
if all three of us are doing,
if I'm doing something by myself,
uh,
that has a time component to it and then you to come in the room and we're all
going to do it together,
you know,
damn well,
I'm like,
let's Jelly doing over there so that it's not necessarily you're competing and
exercise.
It was the competition aspect of the workouts that would enhance,
not enhance but dry people to perform brings you into a deeper level of
yourself.
It also,
yeah,
it was never supposed to be about competing and exercise,
so that's a,
that's a a slight misunderstanding of what the,
the concept of the program,
I think the crossfit games is crossfit and they make a collusion with those and
that's just not true.
It's an erroneous idea.
The,
the,
the idea of crossfit is,
is getting somebody to not die a diabetes anymore.
That crossfit is to change people's lives and to have that spread through
communities and go,
God,
my mom's doing this and now she dropped 50 pounds and she stopped taking
insulin.
I thought the idea of crossfit has just not being able to shut the fuck up about
crossfit all the time.
You're a cross fair.
That's too,
all the best stuff is culty.
And I think that ideas like Maxwell's spreading like from what I'm hearing in
that way is just bread of ignorance.
It's like an ID.
I guess I can say it is.
I dare you.
I dare because of my education,
I guess.
[inaudible]
you know,
bitch,
you know how I roll.
I will walk through this motherfucker.
Darin allow me to dare what happened in that one American guy who,
uh,
I think it was from Los Angeles,
had dropped the weight on his neck.
Kevin,
no guard hair lies.
He's just,
and he's got the best goddamn attitude ever.
He's like,
I saw him this song or two and he's a fucking,
he is a solid motherfucker.
He's great dude.
You should talk to him and the,
uh,
the bar and landed on his neck right.
And landed on his back and it,
yeah,
it was gnarly.
It,
I mean,
it was a clean break.
Like I think he was paralyzed from that incident.
It wasn't like an onset and you know,
they're like,
oh,
we'll wait until the swelling goes down.
Snapped.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's crazy.
At a bar just dropping on.
You can do that 300 pounds.
It can do that.
So,
yeah.
And so there's no hope for him.
That's just it.
Oh,
he's leading a whole new life.
He's got an epoch in his life and he's leading,
uh,
these athletes that are mitigated by different,
paralysis and all that.
And he's,
he's a,
he's a signal,
like he's become a symbol of hope.
And I'm connectedness in this whole other,
um,
regime like in,
in my gym had undisputed,
in Santa Fe,
we've got four athletes that are in wheelchairs that compete and that drive,
and they get through this,
you know,
for those,
Kevin went right into it because he was already an athlete.
He already had that competition,
competition,
mind.
But,
um,
you know,
a lot of those guys,
they go,
they have an accident,
they go through drugs,
they go through suicidal ideas,
and then after they're paralyzed for a while,
they go,
you know what,
maybe I need to,
I'm going to live this way a long time and maybe I need to change my life.
And there's a whole group of community that's doing it
less from the neck,
down the waist,
the waist down.
Kevin is,
it's amazing to me though,
how people take those,
you know,
horrible circumstances and it changes their life.
He's one of the most beautiful lights ever.
Man,
that guy,
I don't think I would go down that road.
I think I'd be looking for salvation and the bottom of the bottle and then just
suck.
Starting a pistol in the morning.
Suck starting a pistol.
That's a nice way to like every morning.
And if that happened to me,
I'd be like,
toothbrush,
six shooter.
Like how the fuck did you get involved in this wing suit?
Craziness.
How the fuck did you tell Tate on a previous podcast?
You wouldn't jump out of an airplane with me.
Oh,
oh,
I just won't,
I'm just a hair pins are really good for flying and it's just not a good idea to
jump out of him.
You,
you got,
you got into it because you were,
uh,
you will have the answer.
How did you get into like tasty answers are amazing to me.
Tell me about where I was born.
The,
that I wreck.
Why don't you jump instructor?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so is that the first time you started jumping?
So I started jumping,
you know,
seal stands for sea air land.
So you train for a variety of things.
And when I first got,
never knew that you didn't know that.
I don't know.
He's fucking with me or not.
That's honest.
I don't know that.
So one of the rare things I did know,
okay,
to see Ireland,
we're going to focus on the air portion.
That,
all right.
So you know,
you get to the seal team,
keep it together till you take,
keep it together.
Three of those fucking Nitros,
two cups of regular caveman.
He's sat off the tilt and let him talk.
I'm trying.
So you get to a seal team and you're brand new and nowadays when you get,
you're trying to pin that is the designator or that makes you a seal.
You have to go through the jump training before you go through static line,
which is analogous to jumping off the roof of this building with no parachute to
freefall jumping,
which is awesome.
You're falling through the year and you're like,
you know,
like the point brick,
point your toes Johnny fly,
you know,
that's the good stuff.
So when you get to the seal team though,
when I got into 97,
uh,
because I was in freefall qualified,
all we had to do or all we could do with static line jump.
So we'd on the plane with the free fall guys and they would just sit there and
laugh at us as we left the plane.
I like 1200 feet are a little parachute walking off the ramp with our static
line and m and like just eat shit into the ground.
And after about a week of that,
I'm like,
okay,
I've had enough of this static line shit.
So I went out founded uh,
civilian skydiving,
drop zone by my house,
uh,
and went through the six hours of required ground training and then seven jumps.
It took me all of two days to do that and then started jumping on my own,
got about 500,
jumps myself and then challenge the military curriculum instead of having to
wait the five years to go to get military free fall.
Qualifacts I was just tired of auguring in on the static line jumps and then I
just really liked it.
And then I pursued a development group was great for it because of like,
what do you want to do?
I'm explaining what development group was,
uh,
developing group of seal team six there.
Uh,
I think in this day and age largely interchangeable.
It didn't used to be like that,
but they'd allow you to pursue stuff that you wanted to do.
And I had a great boss and he was like,
you like to jump,
so you need to go to this school,
this school,
this school.
It's where I learned how to do tandems.
It's where,
you know,
instead of being the jumper,
I was the guy putting the guys out of the aircraft.
So it just kind of led to a very diverse,
uh,
jump experience like I've had,
I've had my toes in a lot of different like jumps stuff.
Uh,
and then a buddy of mine was like,
hey man,
you gotta check out these wingsuits at first.
And at first thought,
I'm like,
yeah,
that looks like you're jumping in a straight jacket man,
because you're zipped up here.
Just like wobbling around.
You look like a little,
you know,
a triangle flying through the air.
Uh,
and then I went and I started base jumping and the guy who taught me how to base
jump,
it was just raving about him.
I'm like,
all right,
that's it.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go figure out how to do this.
And so I ordered a suit that would not be recommended for a normal student
because it was big.
Like the more fabric,
the more performance you can get out of it,
but the more bent out of shape you can get to if you,
if it gets a little squirrely.
Uh,
so they're like,
you should start on this suit.
I'm like,
yeah,
but this one looks way better.
So I'm gonna order this one and then I'm going to eventually jump at this one
and this looks way better.
So I'm going to order both at the same time.
So I order both at the same time.
Did seven jumps in the suit that I was wildly underqualified to jump in and then
just put the big one on.
Look back.
What was the first jump link?
It wasn't that bad.
I was actually in my head,
I thought it was going to be way worse because I mean,
I like to be able to do this,
you know,
like move around and you're in the suit,
you're just like locked in,
you're locked in.
So,
and I'm,
I like,
I had never exited a plane with all that material that I was afraid I was going
to go out and just get smacked up into the wing or in the tail wing,
which has having guys who hit their head and they're just done.
Yeah.
It happens.
Uh,
so I was all freaked out and then I go out and it's like laying on an air
mattress on your stomach.
I just kind of relaxed and I saw the ground moving.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
This is awesome.
You're just flying.
You're flying.
I was flying really inefficiently.
Here we go.
Is that you?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's from 36,500 feet.
36,500 feet.
Do you have oxygen?
Oh yeah.
That's the condensation coming out.
So the exit I'm about to display for you is not very good.
Why?
Well,
I caught my foot on the door start.
So you go upside down?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And the gets worse.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You're spiraling.
Wow.
How do you correct that?
Uh,
you have to dive the suit so you gotta get the suit die.
They get speed and then I'm like,
okay,
here we go.
So you figured out how to dive down and then that that's stops the spin it,
you got to think of the wingsuit,
like an aircraft wing.
If you stall it,
it'll spin.
So wingsuits likes speed,
they just want to go fast.
The faster it goes,
the more power you have.
And I can actually gain altitude in my wingsuit so I can go down and then flare
back up and gain a couple hundred feet.
How far get a couple hundred feet.
Can you continually do that?
Like when does it end?
Uh,
like for this particular jump,
this was in August.
That was 18.25 miles is what I traveled horizontally,
not do you know,
do you know what your speed is when you're going?
Do you know?
Uh,
not really.
You don't have a readout or anything like that on that jump?
Not only did I not have to read out,
I didn't have an altimeter.
All I had was an audible in my ear because I didn't,
uh,
I didn't want to have anything else.
I was afraid that the oxygen hose was going to rap over it.
There was just too many other complications.
So I just went,
went uh,
off of the audible and then I calibrated camera one,
camera two before I left.
So when you're doing this the first time you're doing this,
are you doing it from this high?
Like how high were you the first time he did it?
So most skydiving is like 13,000,
500 feet.
That's,
that's pretty much about it.
But I mean this was,
this took a lot of time in the making like I was,
that's an airplane,
right?
That was an airplane.
But I was started,
you know,
making the preparations for that in January of this year.
And I did that in August.
That was a world record.
Yeah.
That was the farthest distance flown in a wingsuit,
which is a completely irrelevant,
completely irrelevant measure of horizontal distance,
but right.
You know and what time,
like how much time he's spending from the time you jump out until the time you
land.
A I was in free fall for just over eight minutes and then probably under canopy
under the parachute for less than a minute.
That's it.
I pulled a little bit low.
I didn't have an altimeter on.
So like I said,
I had an audible in my ear that was set to go off at certain altitudes in it.
Uh,
the lower beep did not go off so,
but I account I calibrated my camera's before I went or like camera one,
camera two,
camera one,
camera two.
Let's go.
So it was calibrated.
What does that mean?
Camera one,
camera two.
You're calculating my eyes.
Camera one's calibrated camera too.
Let's go.
How do you do that when you look at the ground?
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
this is getting really big.
Yeah.
Wow.
Cause I had just gotten back from a month base jumping in Europe where I was
used to pulling it like 400 feet.
So I had seen those visuals of the ground coming up and I had an altimeter
alerts set for 10,001 set for 5,500 in my last one,
I wanted to go off at three so I got the 10,000 foot alert.
No problem.
5,000 foot alert goes off,
no problem.
And then you kind of have like this mental,
it's going to be after a while,
you know how long it's going to be.
So I'm just like flying,
flying.
I'm like,
hmm,
okay Ma,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna wait.
Right.
Cause you know it's important.
I'm going for distance.
I'm just gonna keep waiting and keep waiting.
And I'm like Ha,
tree down there is way too big.
I'm Outta here.
Wow.
So yeah,
you ever hear about these guys that want to land them?
I'm one of those guys.
You want to land one without a pair of shoes.
And they were saying they land.
I don't think it's possible that landed in boxes.
Right?
The guy in Europe did he put a neck brace on and put up some big cardboard boxes
and fluid right into the box.
And how's he doing?
He's fine.
Walk out of it.
There was another guy,
Jeb Corliss who was talking about like basically taping a skateboard to his
stomach and making this really long.
That sounds like something a guy named Jeb would do.
Jesus fuck his brother.
I going to get all the trucks for the board together.
My cousin cliff is going to try to,
I mean to me though,
man,
I'm like,
yeah,
that,
I mean I would probably give it a go.
If I could rationalize it and figure out a way to like it,
it would be at least plausible or possible.
I'd give it a go.
What would be the way,
I mean I could see maybe in the ocean and it can land in the water now because
you're gonna be stuck in that suit.
Oh,
it's,
it's like a buck 20.
Hey,
yeah,
whack.
There's 20 guys that are doing that this year.
Yeah.
And there's no more of that start.
How many are doing it next year?
We'll the skydiving in the base jumping,
basic jumping like that.
Uh,
I think
18 or 19.
Is there a way that you could have a wing that's not fixed that's like may be
expandable?
Like,
uh,
like you would reach a,
a certain point,
you know,
you're,
you've got your wing like this,
right?
And you're flying around.
Is there a way,
like maybe you could release something that would give you a bunch of extra
fabric and you would just,
it was slow.
You,
I think I've seen this in the bed than fat man.
Hey Siri,
Siri is,
I didn't even say,
Hey Siri was series transcribing that.
If you noticed that series that will,
the Chinese are trying to figure out what you got going on.
The Chinese are doing,
it already broke captain of my shit.
I think I saw that on Batman returns.
That same concept that we're talking about,
but you're going to have the electro gloves.
Yeah.
Well that was thinking that maybe a way that you could release more fabric in
the wings and it would slow you down considerably.
Like you could get to a point where you could hit it and it would puff back and
then you could almost like hit the ground running.
They're for sure going to do it.
Somebody has good body,
but I don't know how long has wingsuits been around?
I mean there's a lot of impossible sisters.
I think
the technological advances in those 20 years are insane.
Like it was literally before a fabric loop that went around your thumb and like
a twin sheet,
but a guy so do his suit and was like,
crikey,
crazy box.
That's like me jumping off the garage with two garbage can.
But it has happened.
It has happened.
It's done it.
So the,
yeah,
the pioneers.
Yes.
Here's an interesting statistic of like the 80 people who are credited with
developing wingsuits.
80 of them are dead.
Is that Jesus Christ and then it's not old age either.
No,
no.
But I bet you they went out with a smile on their face.
How?
I bet they didn't.
How about that?
I bet they did not.
Right before they realize they were going to die.
They had a smile on their face up until that point.
When were smiling right now say that your court doesn't go off when you're at
2000 feet or wherever you are and you pulled,
are you still smiling after that?
Well and that jump that we watched,
I mean I have a reserve so I have a plan B on base jumping and the how close do
you have to get to the ground before it's too late?
I mean I had about a five second canopy ride in Europe,
so I was probably 150 feet off the ground when I pulled.
And you then that's,
that was emotional courage and it was a bit,
that was a visually intense experience for me.
That was the lowest I've ever opened.
A parish is so low,
it's so low.
That's like how many seconds is that from the ground that you're following?
More than 155 seconds.
Well because you're only going about 30 down in your wing suit,
you got more than four speed.
Right.
Okay.
Not,
not like big drive to canopy opening.
I mean,
it opened and I hit the ground.
Like four seconds later I sat down and thought about what the fuck I was doing
for awhile after that one.
Oh my God.
And that for me it was not enjoyable.
Like I do this stuff because I love it and because it,
I mean it makes my head right.
Like if I didn't do that type of stuff,
my head would be,
it wouldn't be like,
I won't be able to think as clear.
It just,
it,
I can't articulate,
uh,
the clarity that it provides for me.
How so is it like you think you need to do dangerous shit because now your past
experience can then,
let me ask you this,
why do you have a sensory deprivation tank?
Well,
because it allows me to be alone alone with my thoughts are literally alone.
Yeah.
Like you're,
are you present in the moment when you're there and you're alone?
Up until the moment where I start tripping.
Okay.
For me,
when I'm standing on like the edge of a cliff,
I,
it provides for me just a moment of clarity and being present in that moment.
Like the closer you get,
and again this is,
I can only speak for myself,
but the closer you get when in the bay shopping world for me,
like when I'm getting ready to jump and I'm zipping up my sleeves and I'm doing
my checks,
like I'm not thinking about my checking account balance anymore.
You know,
I'm not worried about fuck I got to transfer money over,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
It just slowly starts kind of fading away and then you step up to the edge and
it's,
I mean,
I've never seen color so clearly in my life,
I've never,
it just,
it's a laser like focus on the next three seconds in my life.
You're not worried about a minute down the road,
you're not thinking about what you had for lunch,
right?
Because if you rock forward and step off,
you better be ready for full speed life per match.
It you got the rest of your life to figure out what the fucks about to happen.
And it's not that I like to in dangerous stuff and don't get me wrong,
I love the sensation of flying and it's great to be able to fly next to a cliff
or down through set of trees.
It's awesome.
But that,
that moment of clarity,
the only other time I've ever had that is on like a helicopter at about the one
minute out where you lose all of the past and all you're thinking about is the
absolute present moment and the next thing that you have to do what you're
saying one minute out,
me and him about to go into combat.
Yup.
Because you're not worried about your checkbook then either.
It's just that it's,
it's a narrowing,
but an expansion at the same time you're narrowing your focus.
But I'm expanding the amount of information that I can process.
So it's almost like an altered state.
Like you're,
you're reaching like a very high level of concentration,
almost like akin to like a deep,
deep meditation.
Yeah.
I don't know.
She'd be nothing deep,
deep meditation.
Uh,
but yeah,
it's definitely,
it's as close to,
you know,
one of those states that I can imagine.
I mean,
I,
I love it.
It makes me better a better person in ways that make no sense.
Like it,
it gives me more patients around my kids.
It gives me more patients dealing with idiots that I don't,
you know what I mean?
Because,
and I don't know why.
Just those few seconds or moments provide that for me.
But it does make sense.
It balances it out.
You know?
It makes sense that it gives you this unbelievably extreme experience.
So it's like,
it drains your need for that.
I felt like that the first time I did a stick fight and like stick for a cause.
I don't think it's unique to the jumping.
I think everybody,
I think when you start,
because don't get me wrong,
like when I'm standing on the edge,
like every alarm bell in my body is like,
you're an idiot.
You're an idiot,
idiot.
Your hearts discharge,
you get here,
you're on the quip.
Oh yeah,
here's this guy trying to be all tough and talk right.
And you're like [inaudible] are you ready to go?
Like you're spitting sawdust.
But I think if you spit and Sada,
so for me,
right,
that that's the point where I have that experience.
But like you're saying take,
it could be,
it could be stick fighting.
That's why to me like you guys are fucking crazy to go in the octagon like no
way.
Like,
but maybe you guys get that when you're getting ready to square off with the
dude in the octagon.
I think that there's something in who we are as human beings that wants us to
search for that,
but everybody finds it in their own way.
Yeah.
There's something about human beings and wants you to run from comfort and that
you,
you learn from you about yourself.
Some are cleaved comfort.
Well the ones that are interesting,
the interesting,
the really interesting ones to me are the ones that the the seek out these
difficult moments.
Yep.
Cause I know that I've seen combat like you to that degree that that kind of a
soldier,
that fight are all like they have to get worked up like 10 candidates.
Yeah.
Like Tim and Brian Stann are both guys that have talked like that about it,
that they have to get worked up there to calm before they go into that
experience.
They need to get jazzed up because they're so used to like a higher,
a heightened sense of constant.
Well let's be,
let's be honest to me like there,
there's some,
uh,
there's some great attributes that come from operating in a high risk,
high threat environment with high consequences,
but it also changes you as a human being to like a graze you in areas that maybe
like empathy for me is one I struggle with like maybe what you were talking
about before about Guantanamo Bay,
about these radicals coming out.
You've got to kill him for me and for me the Santa,
yeah,
I shit you not it,
it'd be as easy for me is to say is to pick up a gun
and blow dude's head off right there.
If he was one of them,
no problem and go fucking sleep like a baby.
Not a problem.
But you know,
there's,
there's issues that can arise from that to like,
and I recognize,
I recognize some of it in myself.
Like for me,
I struggle with empathy.
Like,
you know,
my kids will fall down and they'll hurt themselves and I'm just like,
just like an,
I don't verbalize it,
but on my couch get up.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't have to be my kids.
It's like I don't have a lot of tolerance or empathy for people who are in pain
because the reality is it's just fucking get up and get on with what you got
going on.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's what's ingrained in who I am.
Well,
it's,
your spectrum is different than there.
That's what I'm saying.
But my spectrum is different now.
You know what I mean?
So,
and that impacts your ways.
And that's going to be like that I think for me,
for the rest of my life.
And it's interesting.
It's,
it's just,
uh,
it's like a hiccup that I recognize sometimes and then most of the time I'm
completely oblivious to it.
So there's some great things that came from being in that environment.
And then there's some just odd quirks that you got to deal with too.
I mean,
there's two sides to every coin.
You know,
the empathy aspect of it completely makes sense because if you're used to
operating in extreme tolerances,
tolerating extreme weather conditions,
danger,
violence,
loss of friends,
injuries,
all,
all of the above.
And then you see someone who just twist their ankle and they're crying like a
bitch,
you know?
I mean,
we all seen your friend below.
Yeah.
And then somebody falls like,
yeah,
but we all have seen,
I mean to a much,
much lesser extent,
the people who train in Jujitsu or martial arts and they're used to getting
banged up.
You know your injuries,
you have a different perception of them.
Like I've talked to people that go,
well,
how many surgeries you had?
I'm like,
Oh fuck no.
Three knees knows this.
They start going through all the,
why do you keep doing it?
Why would you keep doing it?
Like,
well,
you just get it fixed.
As people stop talking,
you're talking about exactly the same mechanism.
It's a rewiring.
Once you get,
once you get to that point where you know,
like everybody is like,
hey,
you should stop.
And you start driving on like things start getting rewired,
right.
You know,
and I don't know man.
Dapped right?
Oh yeah.
They fucking adapt in the craziest ways.
One,
you've got to push yourself into that.
You've got a premise that brought,
all right fun.
We'll have it taints on.
Number five,
he just cracked.
And this is,
I'm in America.
We're not in Iraq anymore.
I can fucking do what I want.
I have a bad Iraq.
You've got a back of them over there for us.
I mean,
we got 30 more.
No problem.
You [inaudible] they don't,
they sell them at a Saks.
Now
what I've been meaning to ask you this,
this stuff is delicious,
but what the fuck is going on in there?
And what does [inaudible] means?
Nitrogen,
the nitrogen.
Uh,
uh,
our roaster,
David's entertained over at,
via Miriam and caveman coffee,
a warehouse.
He made a mechanism.
He and another engineer friend of ours that came in,
Joe,
and they infuse nitrogen into the canyon process.
And so there's gas,
there's gaseous nitrogen that's in here that causes a little bubbles kind of
like Guinness like effect
and um,
I dunno the science behind it,
uh,
of how it all works but can only be candid.
It can't be bottled in the same degree to that,
um,
to,
to where we want to get it.
And I think those little bubbles get you a little high off caffeine better.
Yeah.
Is there any science behind that or is it just that's guesswork.
Very sense.
My own science.
Typical tastes good.
It tastes great.
And then how you want to get you fucking jacked.
I throw one of these down before I hit the gym.
I think David was telling me,
I could be wrong on this,
but I think he said there's three times the caffeine of a red bull.
All woe be enough to stop your heart.
He's a fucking true.
How's that possible?
Don't kill you man.
Did she stop numbers?
How many milligrams are exes of your a weed?
Brownie d I mean moderate kill some people when it goes.
Some people,
Joe,
the weak ones can when it comes to weed,
the edible weed.
I'm a moderate Amani.
When you talked to Joey Diaz,
he's a radical.
I'm a moderate.
He almost killed his poor guy,
Liam saying these PSI.
It tried to hang with him and I was and I was like,
you've become retarded.
No,
not just even tried to hang with them.
Joey mixes up the edibles.
He'll take a 500 milligram one,
pull it out of the wrapper,
put it in a 200 milligram one and tie it up and hand it to him.
So He's more than double dosing them.
Oh yeah,
you would call a chemical.
That sounds awesome to me.
That's right in my wheelhouse.
Before we got boring suits man.
Like how did you go from uh,
from being a hobbyist and kind of a professional training guys to how to get in
with suits.
Let them ask that.
But before we forget about this,
how many milligrams we talking about in this caffeine,
because this isn't a red bill,
like 200 fucking milligrams is equivalent to like three cups of coffee right
now.
Yeah.
I see.
If he has this been tested,
we'll test it.
And we're doing it right now,
Joe.
Well,
I mean like,
like a laboratory.
I don't think we're close but tested for a lot of different things.
My very scientific study go,
um,
gangrene.
I think we should probably find out.
I want to know where do you want into like an altruistic idea of going,
I want to help these guys in the navy seal foundation and,
and where that whole idea came from and you're like,
here's,
I want to still serve and how can I serve?
Because the reason you're not as you're medically discharged,
right?
So then how do I keep being a soldier in this way?
How did you get medically retired?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
so,
I was in for one month shy of 17 years,
so 16 years and 11 months.
I figured the Gov you can spot me 30 days.
So I just say 17 years.
Uh,
but it was,
uh,
you know,
it's bumps and bruises along the way.
Uh,
a bunch of combat deployments blown up a few times,
close to breaching charges,
helicopter crashes,
vehicle crashes.
I got shot in the hip in 2005.
So it's like,
it's succotash of injuries that add up,
you know,
ounces becomes pounds become,
you're done.
You can't do it anymore.
Uh,
so I got medically retired and this actually ties into the question that
[inaudible] asked me.
I got medically retired and when I first got out,
I got out the last day of June,
2013.
And I remember driving onto the base on is like,
awesome.
You know,
all I ever wanted to do since I was a little kid,
as be a seal since I was 11.
Can't articulate why,
it's just what I knew I wanted to do.
And,
uh,
so I left.
I'm like,
this is,
this is awesome.
I got to do,
I've got to prove myself.
I got to experience pre nine 11.
I got to experience war time,
which a lot of guys hang their hat way too much on the combat stuff,
you know,
because it's,
it's really a matter of timing.
The guys after Vietnam before nine 11 got nothing.
It doesn't mean they're not good seals are good soldiers.
Uh,
and I,
I felt like we had accomplished a lot.
Like,
like I was saying,
like we had very black and white,
uh,
metrics for success.
Did we get the guy,
did we not get the guys so you can kind of rack and stack the stuff that you did
throughout your career?
And I was like,
cool,
didn't pay attention to a whole lot of stuff for like six months and then
started watching the news after six months.
And it's just,
it's like every story that I hear about isis taking back Ramadi and you have to
starts in northern Iraq and then they take back Ramadi.
It's like,
fuck,
you know,
it's,
I equate it to watching the tide go out.
It just a little bit at the time.
But the problem for me is that that tide that's eroding is the literal blood
sweat.
And Tears of people that I was with and people that I still know their overseas
and even though I'm out of the military now,
like I'm never going to lose that desire to fight like I,
you know,
and I want to go over there and kill those people.
I do ev,
I think about it every day,
every day.
I wish I could go over there and just canoes somebody's head for threatening our
country and what we stand for and people can hate me for that if they want to.
I don't give a shit.
That's who,
that's what I stand for.
It's who I am.
You know,
you're very open about it.
There's not a lot of people express it in such an honest and an open way.
What kind of repercussions of you had from talking about it like that to my
face.
Nothing.
Of course
on the intranet,
people go,
they'll lose their shit.
I'll get laid and the comments on,
Oh yeah,
well right now I'm sure if we opened up Twitter it would probably be a fucking
bloodbath.
But here's the thing though,
but it's not,
it is nonsense man.
Because how can you know to put my,
like put yourself in like every guy that I know,
man.
And I've had the pleasure to know a few guys that are in Spec ops and that way
there's not anybody that hasn't seen shit that's so horrific.
And that is like there's people that need to get erased.
And I'm with that thinking man and God bless you.
You know,
I think I'm open with it because I finally came to the conclusion that I don't
have any time in my life to be anything other than myself.
And the one thing that I do know about myself is I know what I believe in and I
believe in it enough to fight for it.
And I believe in it enough to die for it.
And I certainly believe in it enough to end other people's life for it.
And I don't care if people like that or not.
That's,
but that's me.
You know,
I would love to see you have a conversation cause you're so intelligent and
articulate.
I would love to see you have a conversation with like a hardcore passivist.
I can start a pacifist,
new violent person,
very easy.
I just put a gun to their kid's head.
They're not a pacifist anymore.
I've seen plenty of pacifists
who fight for their life.
There's a lot of hippies that talk all that piece.
Shouldn't tell somebody scuffs their toes.
Well,
it's the idea.
I think what we're moving towards as a race,
I think we're moving away from being cave men to moving to some higher ideals,
which like we're talking about today,
is the safest time pretty much ever in human history.
It's about as safe as it can get more people than ever before,
but the likelihood of you experiencing violence is probably lower than ever
before.
It's still exists of course,
but there's less of it and statistically it's almost odd.
Obsolete.
But I don't,
don't you feel that the,
I mean,
people still need to feel accountable.
It's like the only dickheads.
If you found a real dickhead that's over 30 years old,
that guy's never been punched in the mouth at a certain slightly.
Nicole got a find their accountability and it takes,
sometimes for some dudes,
they just need to get exed out.
Well,
there's a lot of people that don't,
they've never experienced any kind of violence or any kind of conflict.
And because of that,
they're really flippant about the words and they get in front of the computer
screen,
you know what I mean?
And that,
and that's the thing,
like,
go ahead.
Why saw a guy take a picture of chuck of a Rashad Evans Rather,
you know,
Rashad is a famous photo Rashad shot when he was knocked out by Lyoto Machida.
And,
uh,
this guy handed him this photo with a big smile on his face and asked him to
sign it.
It's like one of the most painful moments of Rashad's career.
And,
uh,
you know,
this guy standing right in front of Rashad and Rashad grabbed the picture and
crumpled it up right in his face and like looking at him like,
dude,
what the fuck are you doing?
You're,
you're in.
He,
well,
he couldn't
like out,
you know what I'm saying?
But you know what I'm saying?
They ain't gonna help you.
But here's a guy that,
let's put that in the revenge.
He knows,
but he knows that he's going to get away with this.
Like this is a guy doesn't respect the,
doesn't respect what he's standing in front of.
Like you're,
you're petting a fucking lion.
You just smacked the line in the face.
You just,
you did just did some space to a professional fighter at the highest caliber.
I mean,
he's a former world champion and you're,
you're standing in front of him mocking him with one of his most devastating
defeats and that,
that comes from not experiencing conflict,
not being punched in the face.
He can't punch somebody in the face.
They know your special,
everybody's special.
Like,
I want a participation trophy just for this conversation.
You will get one
of us get an equal participation one right now.
Mother fucker.
I've talked about this tape that like,
uh,
one of the things that we appreciate about guys who have trained and guys who,
if competed even more so is that they have,
there are some of the,
I mean this,
there's outliers,
there's Douche bags,
but for the most part,
pretty respectful people are pretty cool.
Yeah.
I mean fun and competitive,
but that's not a hobby.
Hobbyists,
maybe you'll find a few dickheads in there,
but guys that are competitors,
man,
fuck,
that's rare.
I don't,
you know,
it doesn't come up because you have to face your demons in order to get better.
And you can't pretend.
You can't pretend and you know what it is.
You know what it is to have laid yourself
all out there and not come up rich on the day.
You don't even know what it is.
How many dickhead black belts in Jiu Jitsu if you met God damn,
it's not even 1% yeah,
no,
it's not even 1%.
And here's the thing though.
More and more.
There's more people that are becoming black belts that shouldn't be probably now
maybe that there's a lot of people that I really don't like that are out there
that get black belts and that they don't,
they've never competed.
This idea that like everybody,
if you stick around long enough,
we'll get a black belt.
Well No,
fuck that you shouldn't,
you don't deserve a fucking black belt.
Like there's a lot of people that don't deserve fucking black belts and man,
you know what I mean?
And you don't carry yourself like that.
I don't even care if you're the best guy in the mat.
You still don't deserve it if you don't carry yourself well in life.
Or if you injure people on the tensions,
a ton of things,
right.
Especially if you enjoy like blue belts rolling against this guy's.
It was,
there was always a guy in every school,
they're like,
will injure people and people will avoid them.
Like get away from that guy.
I mean,
I,
I valued Jujitsu so much that I feel like if you're not carrying that well and
representing that well and you're a bully in the street or you're this or you're
that like you need to walk right man.
That like that is a,
that's a honorable thing that's on us to carry your fucking shoulders and if
you're not,
then that's a problem for me.
Like,
like you're saying,
the guy who wanted him to sign a photo at one of his worst moments,
the guy asking him to sign that photo,
had he taken the effort and the thought and put the work in and of himself
become one of the black belts that you're talking about,
the less than 1% he'd never would have never asked him to do it.
There's something in that exploration of who you are that brings something out
and I think it,
I,
I dunno,
it,
it drives me insane.
I like my sons will have visceral physical experiences.
They can push themselves,
they will be competitors.
I'm not going to shy away from that.
They're not going to get a participation medal.
They're going to get told when their performance was subpar because that's the
way the world is.
And I don't want them being that dude like,
hey here,
chill.
You just got knocked out.
Can you sign that picture?
Yeah.
But when you get out of school and you find out that participating doesn't
matter in that,
you know,
and that and that.
I think that's the difference though too with being a,
and to say it in a different way,
a participant versus a spectator.
Like there's people that are about it and are about shine in their life up into
a whole different way,
don't want to have a common experience and all that stuff.
And then they're pushing themselves towards that end.
And then there's people that are just spectators and fuck you.
Like that's why
people will be like,
people,
people fight for the fans and this,
that.
And I'm like,
you don't have any fucking idea.
That makes me angry.
When people say that you should fight for the fence,
you're not going to fight smart.
And fighting for the fans to put on a show is,
hey,
you get fucking brain damage.
And they don't care anyway.
The fungal fucks,
they don't care.
They'll,
well,
they'll forget about you if you have a poor performance in your next fight.
If you get knocked out in the next fight that defines you.
Right?
How could you even do that?
How could you even get in there and the mindset of I'm going to give us to have,
there's a lot of,
there's guys that demanded stand up fights because they were like,
that's more exciting.
So they weren't very good at striking and then,
but that went a,
when I was fighting at that
time,
that was a huge thing when guys weren't very well rounded.
There were really great wrestlers are great at this.
They wanted to show off their striking skills whether they were there or not and
they put themselves in bad predicament.
I have a friend
who I love dearly,
a great guy who was talking about,
he's a fighter and he made some crazy post about,
uh,
he like fuck technical striking.
I just get out there and bang and I was like,
Jesus Christ dude.
Like what are you talking about?
Like,
first of all,
get out there and Bang Ludwig,
like to have that kind of technical,
yeah.
Like you want to be a high level striker,
like bang.
I think he was as frustrated as at a low point in his life when he said that.
But you,
you,
that's not an option.
If you're fighting and Anderson Silva or you know,
a go cotton sock,
those guys,
real technical strikes.
Yeah.
They hope you get crazy and come out and just do it.
They're going to slice and dice you to pieces.
But you think you could do that to Floyd Mayweather?
I think no one's tried.
Right?
Like,
of course they've tried
anybody else.
Two people have even hit him and his whole fucking career,
you know,
I mean,
but this idea that you should do that and risk yourself and bang it out to like
be more exciting that you're only being exciting to fools who don't understand
what it is.
Right.
It's like saying,
forget about,
uh,
you know,
all the buildup to,
uh,
you know,
figure out,
it is a figure out a song that has like a build up.
Like,
I'm a free bird.
Forget all that buildup.
Just go right into that guitar solo or forget about all the point.
Is the core,
be open to the chorus.
We get all the parts of Rambo that set up the fact that he's angry.
Let's just have a two hour movie of Rambo cutting heads off one side of his lip
up.
Just fucking,
yeah,
that's the whole movie.
No,
it doesn't work that way.
That's not,
you know,
there's wild crazy moments in fights where guys decide to open up,
but they decided to open up ticket.
It's a,
it should be a calculated risk fueled by emotion
as,
I mean,
the best example of that that I remember seeing live is when we went and it was
the first time I saw Anderson fight live and he fought Chris Leben.
Oh yeah.
Chris is a savage and he's great.
He's got good boxing,
he's powerful.
He's all that stuff and he was so outclass that he almost knocked himself out.
Anderson had such great footwork and he was so fluid that he would fall.
He fall down like six times without Anderson touching them.
Like it was just like he'd load up for a punch and then Anderson wasn't there
and then Chris is catching himself on the fence and I was like,
this is next level.
Well he was just,
it was a,
that was a perfect example of the two opposite ends.
Right?
Right.
Like one guy who's just hard ass,
hard,
powerful,
just tough goes after it every time.
Face first.
And the other guy who was a master,
it was just a master and a master of that moment to a master staying calm in
that moment and capitalizing
it wasn't like that.
I mean some of the auto move right out of the way.
Tito go in for a double leg and it's just all facing the fence and it's like
little is not there anymore.
So basically one guy's playing checkers and the other guys playing chess.
Yeah.
And the reality is with those guys,
it's like there's,
there's guys out there that are better than that.
That's the thing when it comes just ended up striking
is when evolution,
like in five years,
those guys aren't even going to be relevant anymore.
They won't even be able to compete at the lower levels and that was an elite
guy,
guys in the UFC that have the kind of standup that maybe like yachts and Cli has
or Giorgio Petrosian
or maybe Keanu Reeves in the matrix,
like you're going to see crazy,
crazy,
crazy shit.
Shut up.
Don't look at me like
shut up with your not talking.
It's still the thing of you know this,
this idea that you're supposed to be doing it for the fans.
Well,
what's fans?
Because the real fans,
the people that actually understand and appreciate the technical aspect of the
sport,
you do it for your teammates and for your coaches and you hope that,
yeah,
you can honor their flag.
Did you see Timothy Bradley's fight this weekend?
Teddy Atlas?
Yeah.
That's the answer to that.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but that's okay.
That was the the,
yeah,
I was going to tell a way long,
more long winded version of that,
but he just said he answered his own question.
Did you see the Timothy Bradley fight this past week?
I didn't.
Teddy Atlas is his coach now.
Teddy Atlas came out of retirement for Timothy Bradley and Timothy Bradley put
on the best performance of his career and tech and Teddy Atlas is fucking
screaming at them in between corn in the,
in,
in the corner,
in between rounds like before he stopped him and he's like,
are you ready for the fight?
The fires common with firemen.
We don't,
we don't run away from the fire.
We went towards the fire.
We live in the fire.
You see Timothy Prize,
I guess coach has coach
and his goes out there and he just stellar performance,
best performance of Timothy Bradley's career.
But it's this appreciation of the technical aspect being coached by a real
master and Teddy Atlas and the guy who he really respects.
He's like,
and he was talking about it before the fight,
like no cell phones in the gym.
No,
no music,
no nothing.
Put all that shit aside.
There's no one in there.
It was just him and Teddy Atlas and they showed them work and adjust those to
jump.
Yeah,
just working,
men's working and you know also you know sparring partners and all that stuff
too.
But like when when their their work and there's no bullshit and showing pictures
of play that play this because this is fucking intense.
This is fucking intense.
Are you ready for the pilot
doesn't bother us.
We live in a,
when you go rent a home,
what do we do?
I want to go beat someone's ass.
Fucking goosebumps.
What's going?
Holy Shit.
That's like coach Man Jack.
Greg Jackson was like that.
We get comfortable where other men are uncomfortable.
You've got gotta become make that make that discomfort your living room.
But he's fucking screaming and he's got that scar across his face where he's
been bottled but he's getting the reaction he was looking for like it's an
effective peace.
He's firing that dude up.
I mean where you jump and that you're explaining that like what do you think?
Like I was talking with Brendan,
Brendan Gibson and bout it and,
and
like the idea of to throw all caution to the wind and let your training take
over and get into that place.
Cause you see guys fight too cautiously and when a guy walks out savage,
they like you and you see that like with the Vandelay Silva never had a problem
doing that.
And,
and,
and what do you think to throw yourself into that experience without being
thoughtful of it?
Does training takeover and take care of you?
Depends on who you're fighting to.
You know some guys you can,
some guys you can do that too.
And some guys you can't like how about Vandelay versus Cro cop?
Like it didn't work right?
You can't do that.
Cro Cop was just such a much better technical striker and Vandelay was Chad.
He was like two 18 just a,
he was a 99% Mexican supplements going in there.
He was barely a human supplements.
He's coming there guns blazing and just tell he's not Mexican.
He's Brazilian.
That's where you get that shit though.
Mexico Bro.
You get it from Mexico.
What do you think when you jump?
I mean these might be underwhelmed sometime not a lot,
but I think is a different thing because the only opponent is your nerves and
your mind and worried about one or two years if it translated to other avenues
of that kind of flow.
Finding is like the technical aspects of fighting are so unique and that you
have all these choices of how to engage,
what to do with how do you agree?
Fine.
You have to,
you got to shuffle those based off of what you're seeing.
Like yeah,
I mean it and you guys wonder micro decisions all the time.
You guys eyes are unpredictable and diverse.
You wonder why I think you guys are nuts.
Like
I tell you,
man,
I like,
I think,
I dunno.
To me,
I think every little boy out there,
it's like,
man,
it'd be dope to be a navy seal or whatever or all that kind of stuff.
Man.
I mean,
I got such an admiration for you dude.
For sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean that's,
that's one of the most difficult and dangerous things a human being and choose
to do.
And I get offended a little bit when you go,
oh no,
what you guys,
it's like I don't understand at all what you guys go through and like the,
the positions that you've been in,
the kind of consequences that are there,
your brothers lives in your hands and fucking God bless you man.
Think Andy might be a little humility here and take,
don't be so sensitive.
All right.
Tell him either get a lot offended or don't get it.
It's just not,
it's just,
there's no comparison being it,
it was a part of it though,
right?
The emotions and the whole thing.
It's an interesting life to lead.
But the most important question of today is how do I get you out of an airplane
happening?
But there's no way a lot of shit already go watch,
go cheer you waiting on ground.
Cause I feel like,
I feel like it's like going swimming with the guys that are the best watermen in
the world.
It's kind of like nobody better to save me.
You can go shoot,
I'll put you in the harness back.
You excited about it after you told me that everybody who invented those fucking
things is dead.
I didn't say my take you for a wingsuit,
John on a window that's on your mind.
That's where it's going.
Listen,
I don't know me well.
We'll walk retarded.
We'll walk hand in hand together.
I don't push you backwards and like harness.
That's me to let that shit go.
Let Shit go
man.
See your ass at all in that.
By the way,
that kill cliff stuff,
that stuff is fucking delicious.
Isn't all like sponsored or created by military people like who's a former seal?
Who is the founder and then the president,
I don't know how they're sending it to me,
but they've been sending that to me forever.
People Send me Shit.
I don't even know how to get my address,
but I get that.
That stuff is good.
That mean that Shit's fun right there.
So they're sponsoring you this kill cliff.
So this was all based around and never got,
never answered.
Tate's question.
So like the footage,
the first jump you watched,
that was all based as a fundraiser.
He actually was uh,
talking with you about it I think on like seven oh five or something like that.
And he's like,
hey,
you want to jump out of play?
And you're like,
fuck that guy.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
kill cliff [inaudible] there,
my sponsor for jumping and they have a commitment to the navy seal foundation of
$250,000 a year to try to give back to the guys.
You know?
And when Tate asked me like,
how did I come up with the idea of doing something to raise money,
it all comes to the fact that like I can't get rid of,
like I was telling you about my desire to go fight and do and continue to stay
involved,
but I can't physically do it anymore.
So the only thing I could think of to do was to do something to try to help the
guys who are doing it and this is what I'd normally do.
So I just tried to tie the two together.
What are the injuries that keep you from doing?
Like how,
like you seem like so fit.
You're doing something that this video is showing you doing all these chin ups
and rowing and all this crazy shit.
So I can't feel my left leg from the knee cap down.
I have from [inaudible] I got so the round missed my femur,
but wow.
What an experience.
They don't know if he had clipped a psychotic nerve or you know,
have you ever seen the gelatin that gets shot by a bullet and has the
shockwaves?
Either way it short circuited the electrical circuitry down my leg.
So from the point of impact,
all the way down to my foot,
it was just completely fried.
I had dropped foot for a year.
What's drop foot?
Can't pick your foot up.
I could always Dorsiflex I could always put down,
push my foot down,
but I couldn't lift my foot up so I had to like have a little plastic brace
underneath my foot.
It was gnarly.
Uh,
and then for about six months it felt like I dip my leg and gasoline and lit it
on fire.
They,
yeah,
this is all just promo stuff leading up to it.
Uh,
so basically what I can do is,
I mean,
I can hide it really well.
It happened over 10 years ago,
so I can train around it and I try to stay as physically fit as possible so I
can keep doing this stuff longer.
So to this day,
that leg is still numb from the knee cap down.
Yeah,
the sciatic part of the nerve,
when it wraps over the top,
it's really bizarre.
Like you can scratch your fingernails across it and I'll get a delayed
sensation.
But it happens like six or seven seconds later.
It feels super odd.
And when it first happened,
I'd be distracted during the daytime and then I would lay down at night time to
try to go to sleep.
And it was,
it was,
it was hell I could,
it would just felt like my leg was on fire and you know,
I went and I got it.
That's actually how I found crossfit was rehabbing from the injury because the
navy's was like Percocet,
Vicodin,
Ambien,
something else that was blue.
And I'm just like,
Ryan Viagara probably that last blue one probably cannot see what I do when
you're all jacked up on Percocet,
ranger,
Captain Morgan.
Right.
Then I'd go with Captain Morgan.
It's fun.
Yeah,
that'd be good experiment.
So I'd fist a bottle of captain Morgan every night I go down the bottles.
I was taking like four or five ambien and not being able to sleep like that's
how far I was playing around with my own pharmaceutical.
A buffet,
if you will,
for how long?
About six months they had me on antiseizure medicine for kids,
which has a secondary side effect of neuropathic pain control,
but it also suppresses your central nervous system functioning.
So I still remember the day we were living in Virginia Beach and my mom,
my wife asked me a very simple math question and I just was like,
I couldn't do it.
Whoa.
And so I was like,
okay.
And I s I got myself and that's,
you know,
I started going to the gym and just working out on my own and I weaned myself
off all this stuff and had to really graduate myself off the antiseizure stuff
cause you can't just stop.
And why,
why did they have you on antiseizure stuff?
Because the,
the medicine had a secondary effect of neuropathic pain control.
So they were trying to control the burning in my leg,
but there was nothing that could really target it directly.
So it was for kids.
But if I had just stopped cold Turkey,
it would have drastically increased my likelihood of just having a seizure even
though I'm not susceptible to do it.
So it took me about another sick.
It was,
it was,
it was gnarly.
Like my,
I can't imagine the Shit my wife put up with.
I would literally drink all night and just play,
you know,
Pez dispenser with a variety of colors that would come at me.
Couldn't sleep,
sleep during the daytime.
I mean,
it was a mess.
And what are we doing when you were up and just surfing the Internet?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't even remember.
I was just loaded,
you know,
and it was,
there wasn't a lot of,
uh,
it wasn't a lot of mechanisms for support back then.
And he was 2005 it was a little bit earlier than the,
the,
the medical systems that are in place now.
I mean,
I,
I still have never had a surgery.
I've never had stitches.
They left everything in a,
and some of it works its way out over time.
They flew me to Germany.
I mean,
fragments.
Yeah.
I got about 300 pieces of frag and my left leg and then the round is still in my
pelvis.
Uh,
it was gnarly.
I mean,
I,
is there a reason to leave it in there or so because there's retained Farris
metal in my body,
they can't really image me with the magnets to get a precise location.
So they gave me the option when I was in the hospital in Baghdad.
They're like,
hey,
you know,
we can try to take it out.
I'm like,
okay,
please describe to me,
tell me more.
What does this process look like?
They're like,
okay,
tube down your throat,
knock you out,
flip you over on your stomach.
Two dimensional X-ray,
start cutting in through your ass,
pulling apart,
looking for the crop.
So I was like made a good choice,
Andy.
Yeah.
I'm like,
can you please describe to me the possible consequences of leaving in?
And he's like,
oh yeah.
Well the body will encapsulate it in calcium and as long as you don't have bone
contact with the metal,
you should be fine.
I'm like,
well fuck man,
why didn't you leave with that?
It's awesome.
That seems like nothing.
So in comparison,
there's a hard spot in my ass.
Fuck.
So anybody who's complaining about that,
but let's just say about what I've been fucking been through.
Reorganize my ass golf ball in your ass.
So I left it.
I left it,
flew to Germany,
stayed in the hospital in Germany for two days,
check myself out of the hospital.
It took a taxi to the airport,
flew home.
It was home like 48 hours after it happened.
Whoa.
It,
my squadron was still forward,
deployed.
So it was kind of on a little bit of an island by myself.
Not by any malicious intent of anybody,
but I was just there like,
I mean that was the navy's thing.
They're like,
here,
this is the solution to your problem.
Like some pills.
Oh yeah,
go figure it out.
Yeah.
And you know,
what can they do other than that you would have,
it'd be like a project.
They would have to have a bunch of people.
It was really help you.
Like I said,
it was early.
I think now they probably have a protocol maybe specifically for neuropathic
pain control that they've learned over,
you know,
over the decade that we've been fighting.
Like look at amputations,
right?
You never used to survive a single,
let alone a double amputation.
But now it,
medical advances are so far down the road that,
you know,
triple and quad amputees are actually surviving,
which would never make it off the battlefield.
So maybe they have something now that that would help.
But that was it.
And then,
so I basically started working out and would exhaust myself and that's how it's
sleep.
And that's how I found crossfit and got introduced to the founder cause they
were founded in my hometown.
So with nerve damage,
there's like a tiny amount of improvement that you get one millimeter a day.
Yeah.
That's that drop foot coming back.
Right.
That's why it takes that,
it takes that long in the doctor's guys who had gone for,
you know,
multiples of the number of years of school that I have under my belt,
it would be like,
Eh,
I dunno.
Maybe that's the answers that I would get him like,
hey man,
am I gonna be able to walk again?
And they'd be like,
perhaps it's a,
it's a practice,
not a science.
Wow.
That was your drop foot cleared.
It's better.
I can hide it.
Like,
uh,
it's funny,
like if I were more like a dressy shoe,
you can hear my left foot hitting a little bit more.
But what really gets me and was one of the biggest things from my military
retirement is that I have a really hard time controlling a roll of the ankle to
the outside.
And the majority of the time when we're overseas,
I'm heavy.
I'm like body weight plus 80 to 120 pounds on my back.
Right.
So you get that off kilter at all.
And I have snapped my ankle over so many times,
almost to the point where I almost called a medivac and it was just like the
purple and the size of a grapefruit.
I just couldn't do it anymore.
You know,
people have like an abstract idea of what it's like to do what you guys do with
a heavy pack on.
If he never wore a pack like yeah,
I work out with a 40 pound weight vest sometimes and I can't wait to get that
fucking thing off it.
It does.
When people that triple that and then go for a five kilometer walk
right into your body,
not something extended off.
You're off balance and I'll hide around the corner and think about,
I'm going to access the enemy with a heavy ass fucking pack on it.
Yeah.
I mean we packed that elk out.
That's out there in the hallway.
I had that on my back.
I probably had like 160,
170 pounds and I only had to walk a half mile,
which that weight at a half a mile would destroy it.
And I was exhausted and I couldn't.
And I'm like,
well,
these motherfuckers are going five kilometers a day with more than that on their
back and get to getting shot and to get to work and getting shot at you up.
Like my friend Cam,
Cam Haynes,
he uh,
w to prepare for elk hunting.
He'll do,
he takes a rock.
He has this hundred 35 pound rock and he puts it in a backpack.
He straps himself in and he goes up mountains with it.
I've seen it and he's got a particular rock.
I've seen his Instagram and he's like,
he's like,
yeah,
I got the rock today.
And what's his name?
Rob Set up.
You got to have a name for it.
It probably does.
You know,
he probably won't tell it.
I know probably some curse.
You're on your own.
You're on your own to train for us like you can do.
There's guys who do the triathlete route.
There's guys who do the Arnold route,
there's guys who did the cross throughout the function.
Like it's everything in between.
It's put that pack on you and send you out.
Yep.
Now are these like a,
they have like load lifters.
Are they like,
like Paul on the harness it,
I mean,
so I had,
I basically made my own because I had all my special things that I wanted to
take with me and they would only fit in like the Vietnam especially
have missiles that I showed you the video.
Oh my God does send you that video.
Know what video is this?
It's awesome.
These is,
there's these assholes that have come and attack the base and then they go out
just far enough where they know a rifle round while you texted me that,
cause those are the things that I'm,
this t javelin missiles,
a javelin missile until he found boxes of those.
Right.
So Welborn was telling me something.
So I went over there and I went to the school to fire those things and I was in
the east coast and forgot about it.
And we got to Afghanistan in 2010 and I'm looking around,
I'm like,
those are javelin missiles,
son of a bitch.
I need to find a launching mechanism for those things.
So I went to an army unit and traded him straight up for a half shell.
Ballistic helmet costs $400 for the launcher cost 50,000 we did a straight up
trade.
I think I got a good head and a pretty good deal.
Took it back to the base and then hook the thing up,
test fired one to make sure it was all still good to go and then just started
carrying them in the field with me.
But I had to make a backpack that we carry them because that would carry two of
the job ones.
And then I'd have my 300 win mag on top of that too.
So that's,
that was my special things that I took with me.
Jesus Christ or Jimmy had just sent it to you.
That is rad.
Those missiles are gnarly.
This thing that set this up.
So then you're aware when you're firing this and you hit that truck.
The truck was like two and a half kilometers away on a hill.
But I mean I,
I think I ended up shooting like 12 or 13 of those things.
They're about hunter 50 thal pot money.
We'll spend $150,000 a pop in the shot.
12 of them,
she's got $1 million where the brown plus in an afternoon,
you're welcome.
Not In an afternoon.
It was like an eight month time.
But dude,
they were so devastating because again,
we're not fighting dumb people.
The idiots that will go in the street and shoot an AK 47 at a predator.
They were gone like a week into the conflict.
It's a mature theater of war and they're like,
oh these guys have five,
five,
six they can't hit us.
So will lob seven six two.
And so they'll stay out at like,
you know,
1500 2000 law PK rounds in,
which is basically,
you know,
300 women gives,
right?
Cause you're a hunter.
It's basically a belt fed 300 win Mag gnarly.
It will get your head down.
Well these missiles can go out to like three kilometers.
So I would go out there and I let these guys sit up and high ground positions
and they'd be over watching our guys in the low ground and I'd wait until they
got a group of them together and then I would just send one of these things.
So they're designed to uh,
hit tanks.
They're anti take,
it's got a double shape charge.
The first one's supposed to go through the smile on his face and he starts
describing this,
all of those things.
I wish I had one at home,
but you would want to shoot it.
You'd try and want to find a target?
I would,
but I had to get an,
I'd go to jail,
but I still would shoot it.
I think I need one of these new levels.
I'll have one of these with you.
We have a bottle opener channel.
We've got a lighter.
So I'd let these guys go out there,
man.
And I'm not even get into the best part of the story because it's right before
it hits.
That's the best part of the story.
The uh,
you know,
I got tired of getting shot at and having an organic weapon on me that couldn't
reach him.
So I started bringing him and you know,
if you want to end a firefight,
you shoot one of these things.
I can't describe how loud great freedom to do that.
I mean to be like they're getting at me and I can't get at them.
And you're like,
you know what,
here's my solution.
And they think they can regulate them.
So they're just like,
oh,
what's up?
And you didn't you,
you launched this thing.
Yeah.
They're like,
you're just beyond my reach.
You're like,
Oh really?
And Joe,
here's the best part.
It has to two settings.
It has top attack or direct attack,
so it'll go up and come straight down so you're not even safe hiding behind
things or it'll go direct attack right at the guy regardless.
The best part of it is,
is about a quarter of a second before it hits.
They make the o face,
right?
They're doing their thing.
They go,
oh shit.
Shinar done best part about it,
which is better for you,
the top or the direct top when they're hiding behind stuff.
And then to you,
how do you judge the drop?
Uh,
it just depends on what you [inaudible].
It's a,
it's a thermal camera.
You're looking through the warhead.
After you activate it,
you lock it on by making this box gets smaller,
it flashes cross hairs and then you pull the trigger and it will hit whatever is
the cross hairs are on.
So you just look at the terrain and where they're at and then so it changes.
It makes it,
no,
you have to pick,
you have to pick when you shoot.
So like if they were hiding behind a wall or something that I,
you know,
I didn't have a direct access to them,
I would just drop it in over the top.
But you can drop it right where they are.
Jim.
It doesn't come.
What do you think of that beer right there?
It's delicious.
It's got damn good.
That's what we make that New Mexico.
That's one of my points.
Is it nice.
So Joe,
those reminders,
those are my special things,
dude.
But again,
I did that because it was out of necessity.
I was tired of getting shot at from a range I could do nothing about.
And what I found was if you shoot one of those things,
they would leave us alone for the rest of the day.
It's the same.
It's the same theory is why would you kill a fly with a sledgehammer?
It's so the other flies take notice,
not because the sledgehammers anymore effective than any,
any other weapon system.
It truly works.
So you know,
I would say I would say an argument was made that I saved life by using those.
Absolutely.
I would think that too.
And I think that what's awesome is that you had the autonomy to be able to do
that.
Whereas like if you're a regular soldier,
you pride don't get choices like that.
They're just going off buddy.
You'd be,
you'd be running that up the chain of command for sure.
I think what's interesting too is what you told me that one day at the gym when
you're,
when I asked you about PTSD and things like that,
and that's fascinating to me.
And I,
and I'd heard,
I don't know who it was speaking about it,
but they said that PTSD wasn't really,
they don't like it being called Ptsd.
That it's because it's not hate it.
I don't like the d on the end cause it's not a disorder.
Right.
That's what,
that's what this guy was saying,
that it's not a disorder,
that it's a thing that is,
uh,
going to pass by and that you can get through.
And that's not,
not,
it may not pass,
but that's like we were talking about to change,
right?
In your body,
it's not a disorder.
If you get sick and you don't get a fever,
that is a disorder.
If you get sick and you get a fever,
that's totally normal.
So if you go out and you do these things that are not necessarily considered
normal or you push yourself beyond that threshold and there's a reaction that
your body has is that does disorder?
I don't think so at all.
I think it should be expected at a time for you to adapt,
uh,
and be able to heal from some of this stuff,
you know?
But as soon as you label it disorder,
people shut down.
So do you think about it like by defining it in that way,
that it limits how people recover from it?
I don't,
well,
I think by defining it as disorder,
you're completely miss characterizing it because it's not,
I think it's a natural reaction to the human body to being in some of those
environments.
So do you think that like the way they used to describe it,
like shell shocked,
that's probably like better.
I don't know if it's necessarily better.
I,
you know,
maybe don't put a,
maybe don't put a precise definition on it.
Maybe just work on having a better understanding that maybe you guys are gonna
need some time and some more so than others.
Because I think this was Tate was getting at in this special ops community.
I think the instance of post traumatic stress is much lower because we are in
control of what we do like I,
the horrific environments that I saw some of these guys getting into like in
Afghanistan in 2010 was a sequential series of the most dangerous months because
of iets improvised explosive devices throughout the history of the conflict up
to that point,
vehicles,
we're just getting vaporized in some of these army guys had a job of patrolling
up and down route one which is the main corridor,
an Afghanistan and they would get in these vehicles and sit there and wait and
maybe something would happen and maybe it wouldn't.
Maybe it hit the vehicle in front of him,
maybe to hit the vehicle behind him.
Maybe it would go a little order and it just flip them over and fuck them all
up,
but they're sitting there when you said they're waiting,
they're waiting to be attacked there in the back.
They're sitting there and I can't even imagine that the,
the,
the geometry going on in the brain of trying to just just rectify that and just
dealing with,
they're basically waiting to be victimized.
I don't like to describe it like that because I don't think that's the right
term,
but maybe my vocabulary is not deep enough to describe it better,
but they're sitting there waiting for an event to occur to them.
They have to be reactionary.
Yeah.
And for,
uh,
I heard a psychologist describe it once.
It's called the locus of control.
Like,
so the guys in the tin can,
they don't have any control there waiting when we go.
And like I said,
we have a much more structured,
much more regimented target deck,
much more regimented success or failure.
What I go 99.9% of the time that I've been involved in a violent event overseas,
it was at my control.
I initiated the violence because I'm going to come to you at the most
advantageous time for me in the least advantageous time for you.
It's going to be nighttime.
I'm an exploit all of the advantages that I have and I'm not going to fight
fair.
Like that's the way it goes.
And I control that.
And so after,
I mean,
just imagine the difference between the two being the pit bull or the guy who's
acids in the pit bull's mouth.
I mean,
like that's in my mind,
and again,
this is just me talking about it.
I think that's why there's such a huge,
or not a huge,
but a greater incidence of post traumatic stress in those units that had little
to no control over what was going on.
Right.
Like the,
the instance of that one guy that was having a bunch of,
uh,
who's diagnosed several times a PTSD had been deployed and then wound up killing
all the civilians.
That was the,
one of the most horrific.
And um,
one of the most popularized,
uh,
incidents of someone,
quote unquote snapping.
Yeah.
And it's that same kind of thing,
right?
Like just constantly waiting for something to happen,
dealing with being attack with no control and you just,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I mean,
they were bearing 2000 pound charges.
They would flip these multitenant thousand pound charge.
Yeah.
So Afghanistan in 2003 we rode around in high lux trucks with no armor
whatsoever because there was no threat of an IED on the ground.
And then we started doing armored Humvees.
But the overmatch or the size of the charge that will destroy a Humvee is like
four pounds because it's flat.
Right?
So then they went to the v shape,
right?
Which the theory is it to flex it out.
So those survive for a while and then they're like,
well,
50 pounds didn't work.
Let's try 500 500 didn't work.
Let's try 2000 and it flips them hundreds of feet into the air and there's
people inside of the things.
I've seen it where they inverted the Wii,
the Wii on the bottom ended up touching the top of the fucking truth back.
And that's what those guys are riding around in.
Not knowing if like I,
I can't,
I can't express enough the respect.
I have the guys who did that because I couldn't do it again.
I'd be back toothbrush six shooter,
which ones are going to be,
that means I wouldn't be able to do it.
I'm not tuned to do that job.
It's such a crazy level of stress and that's why they snap.
I mean,
there's got to be,
everybody's got a cup that's going to overflow at some point and everybody's cup
is a little bit different and some people develop mechanisms that helped them
lower down the amount in that cup and others don't.
Is there any help for them while they're there?
Does it,
does there any counseling or any like psychological training or preparation
training?
I can't speak to the conventionals,
but I can say it was there and available for us.
I can only hope that it was there and available for them.
But do you want to admit that in front of your peers?
You know what I mean?
There's some stigmatisms that come with,
I mean it's a very,
I'd heard that too.
Is that like if I go to say,
hey man,
I'm having some psychological stuff from here,
then you're unfit to lead anymore.
If you're in a command position because they can't put you back in because if
something happens then somebody can come back and say,
he came and said that he wasn't [inaudible].
So it's like you kind of take yourself out of a job if you admit that,
is that not right or something like that.
You can,
depending on how far down the road it goes,
because obviously if you're a complaining about or not complaining about,
but if you're trying to receive help for a certain level of,
again,
I don't want to say a problem,
a certain level of issues that you're trying to deal with at some point that
impedes your judgment and they have to make the right call.
But the guys who were overseas,
they don't want to get,
like,
one of the things that irritated me the most about getting hurt is because I got
pulled out of the fight and I wasn't,
I wasn't done.
Like I said,
like to this day,
Joe,
if I could go get on an airplane and go overseas and,
and affect some difference by going,
getting back on target,
I would do it.
You know,
almost everyone who does what you do.
That's my friend Jody Mitak.
He lost both his legs from the knees down.
He's a Canadian special forces sniper.
And he's like,
I love soldiering.
He's like,
I would love to get back in there and soldier morph.
I could.
Yeah.
And I don't know why I can't articulate that,
but just like,
I can't articulate,
I wanted to be a seal since I was 11 you know,
I don't,
it's just,
it's some,
something in me and the people that I worked with that,
that's just the way that it is.
Is it just because it's life turned up to 10,
the consequences is so high.
The,
I don't think so.
For me,
I mean,
I,
to be honest with you,
I don't enjoy operating and living in environments where you're constantly at
risk of losing your life,
which is why I enjoyed being in control.
Right.
Like knew where we were going,
good intelligence was able to make a plan.
We were going to execute our plan on somebody who didn't know we were coming.
Right.
So in control,
uh,
I mean do firefights can be scary as all hell,
especially start talking about like indoors close proximity.
Like I don't enjoy living in that environment.
That's sucks.
And in the,
I mean there's,
yeah,
there's terrifying stuff that happens.
It's so funny.
Like you'll have an absolutely terrifying moment and then the funniest thing
he'd ever seen in your goddamn life happens all in the span of 60 seconds.
It's like what?
Like dude's making entry on a room that they use for a bathroom.
So they slip and slide and fallen human shit and they come out dry heaving and
I'm just,
I'm leaning up against the wall crying
cause I'm laughing cause they,
they go in there like a bad ass gas
and they come out,
they're just like,
and it happens in the span of 60 seconds and you're like,
what is going on?
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
it's so hard to describe.
Is that in a sense,
similar to this experience that you're getting while you're doing this?
There's these jumps because it's,
everything is so intense.
Everything's so cranked up.
I think I discovered my appetite for the focus and clarity while I was in the
military.
And I think maybe it was something that I couldn't articulate when I was young
that I knew that I was searching for and for whatever reason that particular
occupation called me to do that.
But it definitely,
that occupation definitely refined that in me.
And I think I'm at a point now that if I don't have a way to find that focus,
it would negatively impact my life.
So yeah,
I,
I do think that there is a tie in somehow.
I don't necessarily know if it's linear.
It does and it is not necessarily the risk of life because,
uh,
you know,
I can feel very fulfilled without risking my life.
It's,
I dunno,
maybe it's the impending risk of your life that provides that focus,
you know,
and there's,
there's a connection there somehow I just can't articulate it,
but somehow they're tied.
When you express frustration and looking at what's happening right now,
places that the military had taken and controlled analysis,
lost control of,
now that we pulled out of Iraq and that we're pulling out of Afghanistan,
what do you think should have been done differently?
Again,
you know,
hindsight being 2020,
I think occupation was a bad idea.
I,
you know,
it's just,
it's not sustainable.
I mean,
what's happening to us in Afghanistan is exactly what happened to the Russians.
it's really just moving the dates on a calendar until it's modern day.
It's crazy terrain,
right?
I mean,
it's the Hindu Kush and then it's,
sometimes it's desert.
Like if you get down south in Kandahar,
there's places that are there and they're beautiful.
It's like it's desert and there's green and there's river valleys and then you
get up into the northeast,
like,
you know,
a bad and Jay bad and Kohner it's,
I mean,
it's,
you can barely walk up.
Like you gotta be heavier Billy goat qual to get up those hills.
I mean,
it's,
it's no joke.
Some of the most beautiful country I've ever seen in my life.
Just seems like an insane place to try to occupy given the fact that we know
what happened with the Russians.
Yeah.
Well,
again,
I told you what I would do if I was king for a day that that decision was so far
above my pay grade like,
but again,
we also have hindsight being 2020 I don't think that when they plan to go in
there after nine 11 if you would've asked anybody involved in the planning
process if we'd still be there in 2015 going into 2016 I don't think a single
one would have been like,
yeah,
we're still going to be there.
Well,
not just that,
but it seems like we're involved in an endless quagmire.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't seem like we're ever getting out of this because we've created so
many enemies and that's why I would stop and pull every single person out of
there.
You know what I mean?
It's not going to get,
it's that problem over.
There is not a problem that you're going to win via education,
via occupation.
It's just not going to happen.
Yeah.
Well,
what is going to happen,
this is just going to take generation after generation many lifetimes.
It's going to go back to I,
in my personal assessment,
it's going to go back to being exactly what it was before we went.
They,
you know,
it's like I said that the areas,
Afghanistan is a tribal society.
They don't understand the democracy that we're asking them to utilize.
You know,
we want them to play tennis,
but we're giving them golf clubs.
You know what I mean?
It just doesn't make sense to them.
And you know,
in Qubole maybe it's,
it's largely successful because that's where a lot of the population is.
But as soon as you start splintering out to the areas that have no connection
with cool,
like you know,
it,
there's no way that it's sustainable.
I think it's going to go back to being super tribal.
I think it's so strange too that we go on with all these different ideas of like
what it is that our objectives are and then those objectives get muddied or
changed throughout time.
And so it's Kinda,
it's Kinda like,
I mean just oversimplify,
it is like coming into a gym and going,
well,
what are your goals here?
Do you want self defense?
Do you want weight loss?
Do you want,
and it's like those goals become like this malleable thing that they like.
So now we're nowhere.
Yeah.
Don't spend too much time thinking about it.
I don't man impact where I can,
which is right here for us as civilians to be thinking about is one thing.
But for garlic,
you risked his life over there is walking around with a numb leg.
Yeah.
It's gotta be even,
there's much more intense connection
to what's happening there is.
And again,
so to answer your question full circle,
like why did I start doing the wingsuit stuff and why did I try to set the world
record?
Because I know I can't physically go over there.
Like,
you know,
my,
my number one priority would be to go over there and get back in line with the
guys and do it.
But I can't,
I mean that day has done for me.
So the wingsuit thing and you know,
and it all comes from like,
I wake up in the morning and I watched the news.
I'm like,
God dammit.
Like I want to do something.
And the only thing I can do now is support those guys.
Which was the only reason that I wanted to try to break the world record because
who gives a shit about a wingsuit horizontal distance traveled?
It's totally irrelevant,
right?
That's why I did it as a fundraiser,
trying to raise money for the seal foundation.
They told me you were going to donate a hundred k two.
That's super generous of you.
I really appreciate that Joe.
And then,
uh,
he's pissed.
It's adorable.
Now it's a that mean,
that's why I did it because I,
I can't get rid of that mechanism of like,
ah,
you know what I mean?
For me it felt like,
and when I did that and started going down this road of trying to give back to
the community,
I started feeling better again about my station and where I fit in the bigger
thing.
Because although it's not direct,
it's indirect.
And those people that I'm trying to support are directly supporting them.
You know what I mean?
Like
no way I could justify it to myself.
Substitute.
It's like,
it's like when you say don't overthink and it's like I really don't like all the
stuff and all this is all a midst us.
I can exact change in the community and where I am and the people that I love
and this and then like,
I think that what you're,
that's what,
so when I met you man,
and it was just so inspiring that like the change that you can exact with what
you're doing and with where it goes because you know like the help that's out
there and that's not out there.
And what the navy seal foundation does for guys is invaluable because our
government fails them all the way.
They want everybody to Rah,
Rah the soldiers until the soldiers come home,
man.
And the fight that you're in is vastly more important than,
than you being on the ground somewhere.
I think.
Well,
it was one of the most disturbing things about doing these UFC fight for the
troops,
is that we were raising money for the Center for excellence,
Nike,
the national trends that,
so that's where they sent me when I got medically retired.
Yeah,
it was,
that was the best medical treatment I'd ever received in the military.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's incredible,
but have you visited it by the way,
sir?
Okay,
you should go,
man.
I'll show it's right across the street from Walter Reed,
but I will tell you this.
Is that Bethesda?
Yes.
So it's,
uh,
Walter Reed directly across the street is Nyco.
So if you're going to go over there,
like you need to strap in for what you're going to see,
because that is the landing point for people who come home and fucked up and
you're gonna see amputations.
You're going to see dudes who are three or four days from a really traumatic
event in their life.
And what got me when I was there was not seeing the guys because I was used to
that.
It was seeing their fucking parents,
like the father wheeling his son into Bethesda for the first time,
checking them in and he's got like bloody bandages on him.
Like they're hooked up to all the machines and you can see that the dad is just
destroyed.
You know what I mean?
Because his son is never going to be the man that he wanted to be again.
So I can't recommend to you enough that you go,
but you gotta be ready.
It's,
it's an emotional event.
Like it,
it crushed me.
My Dad came out to visit me and it's tough man.
Like I didn't expect that either.
Like I didn't expect to have that.
I mean I had to go sit down for a little bit.
I was just,
and it just rocked me because I can only imagine what happened when my dad got
the phone call that I got hurt.
You know,
cause I,
I get hurt.
They're like morphine [inaudible] two liter bottle,
here's a cell phone,
call your wife.
And I'm like drooling on myself.
Hey honey,
I'll be home in 36 hours,
you know?
And then she had to call my dad,
you know,
and then I can only imagine what that would be based off how much I love my sons
that Oh,
that gut wrenching moment when you get the call,
Hey,
your son's okay.
But
God damn the um,
what I was gonna say was that the intrepid needed someone like the UFC to raise
the money.
Right.
It was so disturbing.
Like proudly funded.
Yeah.
How was that not taken care of by the government?
How do they have all this money to build like the,
did you say the Pentagon built some $43 million gas station.
They can't justify why they spent so much.
Oh my God,
I read that too.
They can't account for it.
It doesn't work.
Yeah.
0% of the vehicles there use that type of fuel and they can't find the funding
anyway.
Like,
I mean,
I remember when I was a kid and it's like you'd hear it all the time that the
hammer cost $600 if you are,
and stuff like that.
And it's like,
man,
with that kind of graft and nepotism and bullshit that goes on and then these
guys are dot.
Are you kidding me right now?
Hold these.
There's so many people.
I mean,
that's always been the biggest issue with bureaucracy,
right?
There's so many different people that have their hands in the system and they're
not accountable.
Like when you pay your taxes,
you don't get a receipt.
Totally told a,
hey Tate,
they,
they used a 500 bucks to go.
Yeah,
I want,
you know,
most of my money to go to education.
I like a little bit to go to fixing the streets.
No,
you don't.
You don't get that option.
They're just like,
thank you,
thank you.
And we'll do whatever the fuck we want to do with this money.
We're not accountable at all.
So you know when you think 43 million worth of theft,
okay,
if you work for Costco and $43 million is missing.
Andy,
get into the fucking office,
please.
Yes,
I'm missing a few pieces of chicken nuggets.
Would you like to explain yourself $3 million missing a gas station?
Which is supposed to cost a half a million dollars to build cost,
43 million total.
So please tell us what happened.
Uh,
you know,
I'll fucking tax has got to go.
You know,
like,
no,
you wouldn't,
you'd have to be responsible.
You'd have to be accountable.
But this is just a blurb in the news and it'll be replaced tomorrow by some new,
you know,
whatever.
So [inaudible] means [inaudible].
I mean,
that's where I think about conspiracies.
We'll start a new disaster.
So it takes your focus off that,
that shit happened.
And meanwhile,
as Nike is asking for money because they're having problems,
fun,
you know,
funding the organization and I'm telling you,
it was the best.
It was the single reason that I got medically retired.
I didn't have enough stuff in my medical record.
I went there for 30 days,
had a doctor assigned to me.
My,
my exit interview was like four hours long,
150 pages from bloodwork to bone stuff to arthritis.
I mean,
it was insane.
I could do chiropractics,
I could do acupuncture,
all the stuff that I'd never would have thought that I could do and it was all
because of the but Netherlands of others.
I mean it's all privately funded.
Yeah.
If you ever been down to a San Diego and seeing Nia seal training,
no.
You want to go down?
Yeah.
All right.
I can take,
you can take it.
I've been down to,
I flew with the blue angels wants,
which is off San Diego.
You know you grow out to backseat ride.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
I threw up,
I threw up to [inaudible] to the end though.
I was so fucking disappointed in myself.
I,
I kept it together until the end and then I've relaxed too much and then I threw
up.
Yeah.
It's like I held it solid up until the end and then the end.
It's like cheese man.
Yeah,
the end I was,
it was like less at the end that I threw up that I had been through before,
but I just thought it was the hard part was pretty much over.
Then you got to,
you got to be hard about it.
What goes on.
It's stress,
the gs and what got me is not in the turns is about six seconds after the turns
like your inner ear is adjusting and they just like,
you know how when you're getting choked,
you know how you getting choked you,
you kind of like see the lights going dark.
Well this is a slow version of it.
A slower version.
Cause you know if you get choked,
if someone like has you in a rear naked,
it's only like a second or two you have to tap before you going out.
But this is like three or four seconds.
But it's like an elevator door.
Like you know what an elevator doors close and you literally see the black on
both sides and then he hit the barrels hitting a button.
You're like open up and it goes and then it comes back and then hit a button and
the elevator doors are shutting,
but then they come out of it.
You're like hitting the open button so it comes back out.
So you're hooking,
so you're holding onto the straps and you'll like this.
You're forcing the blood in your brain and I'm hearing the fucking pilot and
he's doing it too.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
he's not doing it like they're getting after it.
Those guys are,
yeah cause they're not wearing a g suit.
Yeah,
they don't work g suits.
It'll interfere with their controls of the airplane.
I want the bus and they're all conscious.
All the dog jacked.
All
those guys were like fucking pit bulls because you have to be strong,
physically strong to be able to do that.
Like there's a lot of physicality involved in flying one of those.
It's an FAA 18 is that what it is?
18 Hornet.
I can't imagine it because I know guys that even race,
a race track cars and they're just from turning and they'll be completely
bruised.
They'll wear harnesses to keep them straight and I can imagine what a airplane
that's doing four g like that's,
we went six and a half and that's just because that's all my bitch ass could
take.
Like those guys.
They in that category too that I was like,
ah,
I would like to not do any more of those turns.
And also where's the inflight bag?
And it's like it would be harder for you than it is for me cause I'm only five
eight you're like what three six three six well when you get the tall you are
the more distance which in your heart and your brain,
it's hard to get that blood up there.
Short dudes like me,
like all the,
all the fighter pilots are always so nine,
eight,
five 10 so like when top gun happened and then everybody tried to join the air
force or whatever it was,
or the Navy to flying best recruiting tool for the navy and their window was
like five,
seven to five 11 and then they're like,
nope,
five,
nine and one quarter or else you're not welcome because there were so many
peanut at that wanted to join and that's,
that's why that height is that they want that hype.
For that reason I thought it was the cockpit sizer.
I think it's a lot of is being able to control,
well obviously different planes,
they use different things and some planes that do use g suits,
but when every plane except for the blue angels actually does.
Yeah.
So that's a,
it's an easier if you wear a g suit,
but when you're jacked like those dudes like all of them are like these pit bull
dudes and because of that they can force that blood.
They could stay conscious and deal with a lot of pressure that crazy.
You know like some Larry Bird type dude is just not going be able to hand out.
He's going to go,
I was insane as well.
They're dealing with that pressure.
Their airplane is from me to Joe.
Yeah.
Like they're looking at a single rivet on the aircraft.
That's their marker as a single rivet.
So they're like,
who who like Joe's talking about and just,
you know,
formation flying,
no big deal.
300 knots formation,
flying,
formation flying.
So they're,
they're like really close to each other.
Really,
really seen him.
When I was a little kid.
I remember seeing him.
Him come down,
swoop in and they're like write,
their wings are damn near overlapping.
It looks like.
I mean visually it's crazy.
Well I remember,
I mean there's been many,
many times where especially like in other countries they've done those air shows
and collide with each other and then they go into the crowd goes with the jet
suits or the desks.
I sent you that link on Twitter I sent you to the same night I saw,
well yeah,
these motherfuckers,
they got jet packs and they're flying next to like a DC 10 or something.
Next level.
The new Airbus.
These dudes in Dubai,
they,
it's the next level shit.
They got rigid wings.
They're doing a formation flight with Airbus.
They have jet packs and how far can they fly?
I think they can fly for about 30 minutes.
Whoa.
They were changing positions.
Going to read it on the plane.
Fucking dude is croll Jamie find that it shouldn't be hard.
That's like next level stuff.
30 minutes is a long time and they can go up and then they can,
they can glide,
they can turn the jets off and they glide down cause it's a rigid wing structure
on their back.
When I was in Denver,
oh here's a guy.
Here's how.
Here's why this is so these guys are flying.
How high are they?
Uh,
let's take a look here.
I mean that's like airplane height.
That's lower though.
That's probably sub 10 oh sub 10.
Okay.
That's the guy that's looking at picture on TV on the ground.
Oh my God.
These guys are just flying.
They have jets.
Are they going to 150 300 how fast are they?
They're in the hundreds.
They're not all probably talking out of 200 God,
this is insane.
Your lips are just flapping.
You've got a full screen of yours,
Bro.
Maybe yours will look at those things.
Those things would be flapping like this gets you kidding me?
My Lips have a lot of power behind them,
bro.
I heard
that's over that fucking bullshit man.
Made Island areas sinking.
Dude,
what could,
this is nuts,
man.
This is all Dubai,
right?
Where you can just do anything you want.
The people who pay for this just walk out to the desert and pull out a hundred
dollar bill.
So this is fucking insane.
Looking at these guys with these suits on,
they're essentially like human airplanes.
This isn't just a jet pack.
This is like comic book Shit.
Yeah.
Fucking madness.
Totally spraying chem trails all over the people of Dubai.
Yup.
Look at that.
They are chem trail.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
They just separate.
Look at that guy with his hooping you.
Wow.
That is madness.
It's next level right now.
How long before that becomes like something we see all the time?
I think it's cost prohibitive it,
but right now,
right?
Six years.
Skydive.
Dubai.
That's a place you can go.
Right now they get two drops,
but on the Gotti Bay,
Ron,
I know what you're doing and actually into the fucking parking lot.
They,
yeah.
You know the deal with [inaudible] over there.
It's insane.
Like you've never seen so many million dollar cars in your life,
but they're all over the place.
Amazing like that.
When you're like,
oh,
you know,
I remember asking a long time ago,
I'm like,
what's it like having money like that?
And you're like,
it's like everything's free.
And it's like,
for those guys,
what does that look like?
Human life is free.
Like very like it doesn't matter like a $10 thing,
50,000 for them it doesn't matter.
It really like you meet those really rich guys like then well those are those
guys also there.
Their wealth isn't public.
It's not like,
you know,
everyone talks about the wealthiest people in the world and they're not sharing
that information.
They're not racking and stacking Forbes,
dummy,
you guys are bitches.
You know what I mean?
Kings,
you wear a tie around.
I'm wearing leopard.
We have so much money.
We have so much money that we don't need a list.
You got to gold copper pieces.
Have you seen my diamond and crusted Ferrari diamond?
Well,
I remember there was a great fucking story on TV once about this chick that uh,
she ratted out the sultan of Brunei.
Good idea.
Yeah,
with terrible idea that going to work out great for that.
In the long run.
Dude,
my enough film ever,
he's one of my all time favorite characters in human history because what he did
was he made his own disco and uh,
he had so much fucking money.
Me had hundreds of Ferrari.
So you just had just like,
this is insane.
I'm not kidding.
Hundreds.
And so he made his own disco,
so he has a palace,
it's an enormous palace.
And He created this fucking huge elaborate discotheque where,
um,
it was all just girls that he had flown in.
So you fly these girls and he'd give them like 50 grand a week.
They like giving them like Sitcom money and they're all like,
you know,
these pen house pets and they're all living in.
And they caught one broad with the fucking laptop and she was like documenting
it all for a tell all book.
And they'd given her hundreds of thousands of dollars in jewelry and they took
all that shift from her and kicked her out of the fucking town.
And then she did all these interviews,
but the,
the dude would just come down and his golden underwear and fucking start skating
around like,
do,
who am I fucking,
I'll take you,
come with me.
And the rest of them kick rocks.
You know,
tomorrow,
maybe you'd be lucky and get some more guys like that.
They have hundreds of girls and maybe the most of them,
80% of them,
he's not even fucking,
it's just like there's just here and there and whatever.
And they stay there and they form a little community and all these little holes
just hang out together and pal around.
And this,
I mean it's just total next level shit because this is happening in current day.
So they would,
they would also pay celebrity girls extreme amounts of money to join the hair.
Fuck,
fuck.
They'd fly him in.
Floyd Mayweather did that with like Nicki Minaj.
He's like 50 grand to come up and talk to me for a half hour in my hotel room or
something.
There was something like that I read before his last fight and it's like
there's,
you know,
people will fuck you money like that.
They're like whatever celebrity.
But he's got their price.
Yeah,
but I think the Nigga mountain mine,
the amount of money that these guys have over Floyd Mayweather.
Of course it's like Floyd Mayweather over like the dude who works at Starbucks.
It's insane.
It's like the,
they have trillions of dollars.
Like we would think about like the richest people in the world of worth and like
$90 billion.
What does this champion just pulled up?
This plane?
That's probably a plus.
Salt number.
Nice plane.
Oh my God.
It's got a pool in it.
His plane is a pool in it.
Is that a pool where they,
is that like a,
I think it's a glass bottom.
Did is it's a pool.
No.
What is that magic carpet.
The floor is a giant screen,
which was show the floor.
It's all fucking squirrely looking.
Can you make it larger so we could see it better?
That is insane.
Oh,
it is a floor.
I bet you just gotta kick.
They got a camera underneath it,
probably projecting onto the floor.
Okay.
It's a screen show,
the ground,
you know that they're going to do that now with planes.
They're going to make the entire roof of the plane and led screen or an LCD
screen where you're gonna be able to see the actual outside of the plane,
like the clouds and all the [inaudible] transparent technically.
Seriously,
yes.
It'll be a screen and this screen will project they've,
they've already like made prototypes of these and they've shown like videos of
what the planes of the future would be like.
But the entire top of the plane,
like from the windows up,
we'll all just be the actual clouds that are above the plane.
Saw Buddy he flew to,
he might've wanted to
buy and they were in first class for whatever that trip was.
And the whole wall of the plane was clear.
It was like a huge window and they were like,
it was almost like their first class was like a,
um,
like a living room experience is crazy.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I was talking to Kyle before he left to go fight this weekend and I was like,
well what's business class like?
And he's like,
dude,
you laid down,
they come bring you a mattress.
And like,
I'm like,
that sounds awesome.
And I'm like,
what's if business class he's describing FirstClass better than first class in
America on Quantis and,
and uh,
I've done it.
Firstclass I need to get an apartment.
Yeah.
I was like,
what's first in department?
It's like a your own pod.
I remember already posted pictures once.
Yeah.
Ari flew with me.
It's like your own room.
You,
you're,
you're not only does your chair fully requiring reclined,
but it's turns left and right.
And then you have two TVs just in case.
I don't really want to have to go to the effort.
I'll just make my chair like our would come over and sit with me cause it's like
a fucking 15 hour flight.
It's a ridiculously long flight.
Yeah.
Dan Ari may or may not have come on board with some pot brownies.
It stunk so bad.
I made him throw them out.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Not the country.
You want to mess around.
I got mad at myself.
Yeah.
That's the one place where Sylvester Stallone got busted for Hgh.
Well he came in his private jet with like cases of the shit that,
that homeboys just fucking mainline.
I just saw a little bit.
But yeah,
if you come in with,
hey man,
I don't blame him.
He's my canary in a coal 90,000 years.
That's awesome.
Him and he going to sell 107 in that,
in that movie a grudge match or whatever the other night.
And I'm like,
how do you not get behind the argument to be enhanced?
Like if you look at a normal seven year old guy and you look at Sylvester
Stallone and like that's better.
Well,
do you remember that movie that he was in?
Um,
bullet in the head while he was Shah reddit where it's Jason.
Jason Momoa was in it,
right?
I think like Jason Mamoa,
I think 67 years old,
just as all hell muscular Ini.
It looks like you had some kind of surgery on his pack or something as long time
ago,
long time ago.
He all his rocky movies.
You see that too.
It's almost like he's got like a cable that connects is peck to his shoulder.
Why not though?
I mean seriously,
like if,
why not?
If it's not a financial barrier to you,
I mean the only negative side effect of that stuff is you immediately stop
aging.
Instantly say that it's even a cost benefit because of all the stuff that you
move aside,
that you're going to have health risks at any way that you're not,
that you take away by being a better conditioner g to do things and enjoy things
like the idea that like it's,
it's a manly thing.
Like people like,
well where do you get your testosterone from,
Bro?
I'll give mine from my balls.
You got to get it from him,
Bro.
No,
but I mean that's like hilarious.
The argument,
right?
Where did your from Bro,
I'll get my from my balls.
You know like this,
get that.
Mine goes balls.
What do you,
where do you get your fucking tooth paste from?
I get it from the grocery store.
Shut up.
Give it 20 more years and see if you still got the same answer.
Charles Poliquin and he talks a lot about,
it's really a Charles Poliquin Polokwane is,
it is a strength coach like old school dude.
Well how about your boy,
Louis of Westside barbell.
Awesome.
God also awesome.
I got his fucking machine back there.
That the reverse.
That's a game changer.
That fucking like the sweats,
like who kind of take his uh,
Gospel and spread it.
Shane sweat and Laura's Phelps sweat lowers the strongest woman in the world and
how planning is in her last name is sweat.
Yeah,
Dude.
Well it's Shane's name and shame is probably the best power and speed strength
coach everybody thinks is just power lifting.
And Louise like that's such a misnomer.
It's not what I'm about.
Like he changes the dynamics of whatever kind of athleticism you're into.
If you're a cross country athlete,
if you're a swimmer,
if you're a power fighter and um,
it's a trip.
I believe that if more MMA guys got into it,
they would turn in touching boxing into fucking knockout strikes me.
Matt Brown has done a lot of work.
Yeah.
That's who works with them all the time.
Him and Shane are really good friends and he and Louis and then,
um,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing man.
Westside Barbell,
they'd have more power behind the strike itself are,
yeah.
They are learning how to turn into it more and they're learning how to
accentuate their top end power so that they can actually turn that over and as
opposed to like moving slowly through movements and,
and teaching explosivity.
Okay.
You know,
I had the bigger,
stronger,
faster guys on.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
you know,
Mark's a good friend.
He's a great guy,
great guy.
Mark's great guy.
And we were just talking about the,
the stigma that's attached to these substances because of the idea of cheating.
Sure.
You know,
when you look at like baseball and you'll look at cheating the great American
pastime,
right.
You know what's going on with Russia right now?
We're talking about they're,
they're literally gonna pull rush out of the Olympics,
widespread documented cheating program on the state level.
Like they're just cheating.
They're like,
here's the protocol.
That's,
that's what they've always done.
I mean,
that's,
that's been going on from the beginning of time and then I said what everybody's
been doing at the Olympics,
they found out about it from the Russians though.
The Russians were the first,
yeah,
that money's Germans,
right?
Yeah.
Germany was eastern bloc countries.
I feel like that,
I mean when you started talking and you had that Novitsky dude on here or
whatever,
and in talking about genetically changing things in the miles stat and
inhibitors and all that kind of stuff,
it just seems like at a certain point,
if you want to have natural athletes like saying the UFC in 15 years,
everybody in the stands is going to be in better shape,
in better condition than the actual athletes.
So you know what?
It's going to be alive.
It's going to be like turning your own butter and riding a horse to water.
You're mitigating evolution.
It's like congratulations and the and the reasons that they're doing it are so
foolish sounding.
They just sound like children.
Well,
I get it.
Because like what you get out of competition,
if you see a guy who was gone through an eight week training camp,
he's fighting Chris Weidman versus Luke Rockhold bolt guys,
we would assume clean,
you know,
training their entire life.
Getting for this moment,
the amount of discipline and focus that's required to get through that fucking
camp.
God damn brutal.
It's soul searing.
You know,
these guys are getting up every morning with exhausted bodies and they're doing
their strength and conditioning.
They're doing their sparring,
they're doing all their,
their technical training and they're fucking tired all the time,
man.
They get through it and it's one of the things that v tour and Weidman had added
it.
The weigh ins were widened,
pointed the finger at him.
He goes,
you were fucking using during camp because they did their blood screens and
Weidman's Vitara had a testosterone use exemption.
Okay.
For the longest time,
and it's testosterone when he was on was off the charts.
They,
he would just three times a human jack kind of shit.
1475 was the highest number that he tested for right during camp,
while they're in camp,
this is after they take his testosterone away.
Okay.
They say that you can't use it anymore.
He tested 1200 and Weidman tested 300 and so widens like what the fuck?
He goes,
you were using during camp.
And he goes,
I'm not,
you know,
I'm gonna make you fucking pay for that tomorrow.
And he said it to them after weigh ins and you could see the look in Vitaros
eyes.
There's like,
there's a look that a guy has when he's guilty the most color grade,
the only,
the only real smart explanation for that,
for against it was when I listened to Ron to talk about it.
And she goes,
they know when they're off it that they can't be like,
yeah,
she knows she's done.
I know I'm 100% me.
Sorry Bitch.
If you come in like that,
right.
You know,
you've already lost.
She's like,
I bought.
And I was like,
that is huge because the psychological effect,
we saw it when guys came from pride and they came over,
they would break and you're seeing guys that are top level savages break and
then you're like,
that is a different athlete.
Well it's a different human being because you're not enhanced anymore when
you're a jet.
Like can talks about the ways your belief of course,
because you know what,
you know what you were capable of.
These superhuman performance is when you're on it,
their chin would be better,
everything would be done.
They get it more in the Cape up then hang the,
hang up the Cape,
hang up and take away the fucking the super ring.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
I mean once you've tasted that.
I,
and I don't know,
I guess guys were taking the uh,
well the shitbox guys get their hands on.
Remember when there was a thing and it was all the chute box guys and they would
get touched and they would go out and they'd be out and then they get touched
again and they'd come back on and it was like there's something like as soon as
he hit the ground,
he popped and it was like,
it was like almost an impossibility to knock him out.
It was like there,
that's why I was what they were fucking doing.
It was so impressive when Vandelay got cro copped.
Yeah.
Cause even all that,
I mean that was the heaviest Vaneulla he'd ever been.
He was like two 18 cro cop was only two 14 cro cop is actually lighter than
Vandelay even though cro cop had fought heavyweight,
God is his entire career and Vandelay really,
his optimal weight was 185 and he was fighting as a heavyweight.
He was 183 pound champion.
Right.
Or the 203 pound champion.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what it was.
Right.
And,
uh,
you know,
get to the UFC drops down to one 85,
because he's not on the shit anymore,
but when he's fighting or allegedly,
but when he's fighting cro cop,
even after all that,
but we
don't even know what the fought cro cop was doing.
That was one of the biggest,
strongest guys ever wrestled with.
Like that guy is,
he's,
he's strong.
He's like one of those different levels.
Shop said to him,
he said he couldn't believe how strong you are.
He is powerful.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean his fucking Kao Powers Legendary.
Yup.
You know,
but again,
those guys,
they just had an open agreement.
You just do whatever the fuck you won't even open agreement.
You better do it.
Yeah.
It was in the contract.
Our buddy.
Yeah.
Stop it.
It was in the contract contracts that we will not test for steroids,
but our buddy went over there and he was a natural hundred and 70 pounder and
they wanted him to fight at one 85.
He was like,
I don't even weigh 185 people.
Totally.
Dylan.
Woody,
we can do this.
I don't want to,
and they're like,
no,
this you do,
we have the doctor.
Like it's like
you're not going to not do it.
The guys at the pinnacle of their game,
if they're not doing that stuff,
honestly I'm surprised like I have zero problem with that whatsoever.
Like no problem is it wrecks your endocrine system and after you could show off
of it you're,
you're done.
I mean these guys are there,
they're on these hyper human levels in their twenties and then they get off of
it and their balls don't work anymore.
I see that the teams,
two guys,
they researched the ingestion portion and they're like,
okay cool.
I'm done.
No post cycle anything.
And then they're just,
so what is the protocol when when you're,
you're involved in that,
like is that like from the top down,
do they tell you about it?
Like how does the steroid use in the military is against the UCM J so if guys
are going down that route there,
they're doing it on their own underneath the radar.
However,
the drug testing in the military does not test for steroids and it's a very
specific test it had.
You'd have to be picked out and ping for that reason.
So they're not going to,
I mean it's kind of like this a known thing.
It couldn't be done.
You know what I mean?
I know about it.
How could it not be known?
It was blind.
The blind eyes system,
right?
Like we want you to be an ally in a sense to go.
Yeah.
Right.
But then the guys,
you know,
they don't have the education or they don't take the time to figure out the post
cycle therapy stuff and they just go.
Especially the dudes who were just juicing right before deployment,
then going to the old Turkey,
right when they get on it.
Oh Daddy.
Oh yeah.
It's horrible for your morale,
for you guys on it the whole time they're over.
Well that's Kennedy who say,
Tim Kennedy was saying that.
He's like,
it's,
it makes you a better soldier.
I am all for it and it will,
it will make it dries faster,
recover better.
Talk to team guys that are out now that are like,
it's shit like guys get popped for that when they're in buds and they're like
fuck those guys.
But they're like,
when you go over there,
I want everybody that's next to me to be as big and strong and as alert as
possible.
So when they go through buds they test them for it.
Now again,
it's the same.
It's the steroids I don't think would help in buds.
I think HGH might on the recovery side of the house about like EPO that was
probably helps out blood doping,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know her.
Nate's,
you may have more
balance shuttle damaging thing bugs is from what it sounds like.
Did I don't think that stuff would help you.
It's not as bad as you think you guys were talking about on that same episode.
They don't drown you in buds.
Yeah.
I think you were saying that they drown.
You know they,
we get you as close to drowning as possible,
but it's not her.
But telling drown the last guy to data buds,
a aspirate it on his own vomit underwater and was not recoverable.
But a lot of the,
a lot of the training [inaudible] ago,
probably five years,
the guy dies.
There are probably about once every five to seven years,
which is important.
It needs to happen,
right?
Because that means you're taking,
the training is arduous enough that it's going to do what it's supposed to do
because they're going to die.
It's a terrible thing to have happen,
but so a lot of the training we do in the water is to make them uncomfortable.
Like my favorite,
one of the evolutions in first phase is you get these huge classes of like 150
guys and everybody's like teamwork.
We're in this together.
And you make them jump in the pool,
fully clothed,
and then the instructors get on the outside and you start pushing them closer
and closer together.
Right?
So now on the outside of the edges,
you're in the pool with them.
So we're making a big circle of students smaller and smaller and smaller teams,
water 20 feet.
So it drowning each other.
It,
it doesn't start that way.
But the teamwork talk goes out the fucking window.
Yeah,
it cause then it's like dudes like
foot on top ahead and that's actually the evolution that the guy aspirated in,
which is why they increase the instructor ratio.
They didn't notice it right away,
but that's one of the highest attrition evolutions at buds is that one right
there where they push everybody together and then once they get them together
it's like okay,
take off your right boot.
So then everybody's got to undo their boot and throw it out of the pool.
Take off your left.
But so you're like you have a task to do while staying alive without trying to
kill somebody else.
And just that,
that type of stuff in the water,
the attrition rate is just through the roof I would imagine.
And how long you're in there for?
As long as it takes.
How long does it take to do what?
To get a,
you know,
you take all your top off,
you take your pants off,
you take your boots off,
all that stuff that can take,
you know,
the pool party it is well,
and obviously we are wearing the UDT shorts,
which are just completely unexpected.
As soon as I know,
say they don't wear underwear.
That Bryan singer Guy,
the guy who uh,
directed x men,
he had parties like that.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know man.
The vendors.
Which one?
It,
I don't know if these were the type of party,
but now what happens if guys go,
fuck this,
let's push an instructor out of here.
That would be interesting.
I've never seen happen there that we're going to end up killing each other.
Let's break the circle open.
You know,
I don't know what,
I only had a student grab me one time because one of the tests we did is they
could be such a horrible idea,
but I'd love allow me to tell you what happened to this particular student.
So one of the tests we do,
you have twin 80 scuba tanks and you have to tread water with at least,
uh,
your wrist above the water for five minutes.
And it's really not that hard.
If you can just relax and just take a deep breath and put your head down,
you can,
there's a lot of buoyancy that you see,
you tread water,
but your hands have to stay [inaudible].
So you just use your legs and you have a full scuba tank system on your back,
which if you don't rig it properly,
it'll pull you back a little bit.
A lot of it is just kind of getting your lungs over your center of gravity,
like waters without your hands is fucking hard.
It's hard with hands too.
Yeah.
I mean the training is supposed to be hard.
So really from what I've been told,
I went through the correspondence course,
so I don't know.
But
through the Gracie in action,
he always starts the same way,
right?
Like,
they'll take a breath and then they're like,
they're keeping their hands above water and their head is,
keeps getting farther and farther and farther.
And they had to just like kick,
kick,
and then you know,
it's about to get really bad when they do the monkey Paul,
when their hands started doing this number,
they start like,
that's when you're,
the guy's about to either quit or go under.
And I had a foreign exchange student,
I think he was from Korea.
And they have a weight belt on too.
There's a 20 pound weight belt on her.
Well of course.
Why wouldn't there be?
So a lot of the times with the students will do is they'll drop their weight
belt when they think they're going to go under.
So I as a helpful instructor will get it for them and put it around the back of
their tanks so they can no longer take it off so they can finish the evolution.
Because just because you quit,
you're still gonna finish the fucking five minutes,
you know what I mean?
Like it has,
it has a purpose.
Right.
Uh,
and if you don't quit and you just fail,
will allow you to re retry it at another date,
but you're going to finish the five minutes with your best attempt.
So I'll put the weight belt on the top of the tanks.
So this Korean kid dropped his weight belt and like,
yeah,
okay.
No problem.
Went down and got it,
put it back on.
Uh,
he started going back under again.
It got to the point where he pulled his own life jacket and it inflates and
brings him back up.
So I helped them out.
I pulled the release valve,
let all of the oxygen,
or not the oxygen,
but the co two out of it.
So he starts going back down again and just comes up and gets one big like hand
out of the water and bear hugs me,
tried to take me under water with them.
It's the only time I've ever seen an instructor actually get grabbed.
So I just knew it was me,
so I just relaxed,
held my breath.
We went to the bottom until he passed out.
Whoa.
Who said,
all right bitch,
let's do it.
That's fine.
I come,
I'm like,
all right,
can you hold your breath?
I don't know.
I mean I'm nothing impressive.
Probably a couple of minutes longer than that guy could in a panic state.
That's all it mattered.
You know what I mean?
And you,
and you're in a panic state.
You got about 30 seconds and you're right.
I mean,
how much time do you have?
I probably wasn't going to be able to do a Max breath hold cause I was laughing
pretty hard at him.
But so far that's the whole shit about,
I get comfortable while they're fucked.
I live underwater bitch and he's just like looking at me like,
ah,
I'm
just goes out.
And then you pull them up and it doctor with seven years of medical school and
residency under his belt goes wake up and then they wake up and hey,
you failed.
So he blacked out under the water.
That happens all the time.
We bring people up who,
let's just literally drowning.
It's just blacking out underwater.
But there's no evolution in seal training that requires you to black out.
Like one of the tests is a 50 meter underwater swim.
When you jump in,
you have to do a front somersault swim to the other side of the pool of touch at
front somersault and swim back.
That's another one that gets a lot of guys on.
Uh,
they'll pass out because they just don't want to give up.
And again,
all this stuff is about teaching you where the boundaries,
where you think they are and what other people tell you you can do.
And when you get alarm systems in your body,
it's,
it's a choice to,
to listen to those things.
A lot of the times,
a lot of navy seals or various a Spec ops guides go into like ultra marathons
and shit afterwards just to try to push themselves to the once you,
I mean honestly like Joe was addicted to it.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
I would imagine that you probably,
I mean,
do you miss fighting and do things that challenge you physically and mentally to
continue pushing yourself and growing?
I mean,
once you get a taste for it,
I would imagine you still do those things too.
Don't you?
Well there's a certain amount of you're always going to want to push herself
cause cause cause you,
if you feel like you,
if you're not doing it,
if you're not testing your boundaries,
it Kinda feel like a pussy.
I feel like it's mastery too.
It's like yeah you get mastery over this thing and then what happens with people
that are uncommon and interesting,
they go on to the next thing,
this thing and then they want mastery over that thing irritates him that they
don't mass.
They're like oh man I suck at this.
This shit is good for that man.
And that's the one thing that's been the prime difference in my life is like go
into something and do something that kind of makes you nervous every day.
Go on,
go on,
go into fear based Shit and then live there and figure that out.
Hiding.
It's the only way to live.
Rewarding in addition to being exciting.
Reward is huge.
The exciting thing for me is like that's the initial moment,
but then the impact it has on your life.
I mean they,
there's two different full spectrums.
There's like in that moment and then how it changes you as a human being.
Right.
I got to bring you guys down.
Check out seal training.
You guys.
Let's make it,
let's make a video a day.
They may frown against that.
Oh,
okay.
But you can make a video when I jumped though with you.
Yes.
Cause well Joe will be in the plane as well.
Also,
I'll be wrapped to the wing
with a video camera looking at smaller getting look,
if you don't let me take you jump and we got to go hunting.
Okay.
What do you want to hunt a duck?
Oh,
well no.
All the out the woods hunting you guys hunting duck.
That's an additional oil I need to bring up.
That's going to get in the way of concentrating.
Here's the video.
Here's the video ended with this because we're basically out of time.
We just did three hours,
believe it or not did we really flies by every time.
Um,
so explain this will you as just the javelin missile,
but you cost 150,000 US dollar.
This is what we were talking about earlier.
For people listening.
Andy,
uh,
essentially has a,
this is a top attack.
It's like a sewer pipe attached to her shoulder.
This giant fucking,
yeah,
with a computer attached to it.
And it's about to launch.
So these guys that you're launching against,
tell us the background on that.
It's just a truck,
a truck full of guys and they're shooting at,
you know,
that's done.
Okay.
They were shit.
And this is not their dancing.
Okay.
There's the,
there's the,
the round fires off climbs.
It's hard to see.
But then you'll see where it lands.
Oh my God.
So that is far.
How far away is that?
It's about two kilometers.
So it's,
it's quite a bit slower than a bullet.
Oh,
very much so.
Yeah.
Cause it's so much weight to it and the,
the round,
the guy laughing,
that's so fucked up.
People just die.
Ha Ha.
Yeah.
But you know what?
Those people weren't me.
So it's celebrating they were bad guys.
Right.
Let's celebrate.
Boom.
That's crazy.
That,
that,
that exists.
Reach out and touch somebody.
And what is that going to be like in five years from now?
It's going to be something even more insane.
They already have like,
you know,
like suicide drones now and all sorts of stuff.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
just drone warfare alone,
you know what I mean?
Then that's what they're going to be able to do with these Boston.
Um,
what are they called?
The Boston Dynamics,
those,
uh,
those crazy robots that they have.
I mean,
they've got those robots you can kick and they fucking go or sideways.
So it's not just going to be drones that fly.
It's going to be drones or like you're going to see an army of fucking
terminator robots learning into camps and they can go up hills,
man.
Hey,
you know what though?
Good on them.
I'd rather have that luck.
Yeah,
totally.
The Airforce Academy for the first time a few years ago,
graduated more,
uh,
non manned aircraft pilots and unmanned aircraft pilots in their history and did
they graduate and through Xbox live?
I thought that was a Prereq to recruit them.
Those motherfuckers probably,
it was a Prereq.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm sure.
Well,
listen to Andy.
Thank you very much,
man.
We gotta do this again.
Thanks for having me,
man.
Awesome dude.
Let's do it again.
Without a doubt.
Sure.
Tait Fletcher,
Tatum.
Maximus.
No longer,
and that was just straight up Tait Fletcher on Twitter.
Um,
and my live is fuck live is fuck pirate life,
a iTunes,
all that jazz,
all of iTunes and stitcher and all that right now off is like a cowboy Cerrone.
And then Kyle milk I just put up today and uh,
apparently the UFC is mad about the,
the one with Donald.
I don't know why I don't understand it is a failed drug test allegations.
Well that he,
he knows he did.
He,
well,
anyway,
whatever fail.
He just wasn't there,
but they told them where he was.
He was in Vegas.
It's a long story.
Anyway,
pirate life to,
to find out the full details.
Caveman coffee,
see o.com each and every episode we drink.
Caveman coffee is the best fucking coffee on the planet earth.
And we've got an answer.
It's 240 milligrams caffeine,
so stronger than red bull.
Stronger than your mother's pussy.
And uh,
we'll be back.
See You tomorrow.
Bye Bye.